hello everybody welcome back to the speed
chess championship grand master robert hess
alongside me today is my good friend my partner
grandmaster daniel nardiski dania are you ready
for what will undoubtedly be an epic match up in
the quarterfinals of the 2020scc hello robert good
to see everybody good to be here i could not think
of a better way to start uh the morning on my end
than this absolutely epic speed chess championship
match between wesley so and yon shishtoff duda
i don't know any other words to say this is going
to be epic i i can feel it in my bones well i
believe that judah has a lot of work cut out for
him because in previous iterations of the sec they
have gone head to head and it was wesley show's
taking in that match however duda is a new player
he's improved in the last couple years so what do
you think you play these guys more than anybody
yeah duda has definitely improved i've i've had
a lot of experience playing both of them and
in blitz and in the case of wesleyan classical
they're both absolute monsters they're a joy to
watch uh and they're both so universal and it is
important to point out that duda has really really
improved in the shorter time controls robert he
is going to be a force to be reckoned with in
the three-minute portion but particularly in the
bullet that might be the match deciding portion
but we'll obviously have to see so it might be
a tale of improvement but wesley is a stalwart
he certainly is and while you're talking about
time controls let's remind everybody of the
format for these speeches championship matchups
as you see on the screen in front of you that
there will be an hour and a half of five minute
plus one second increment blitz followed by a
full hour of the three plus one and then we
get down to the 30 minutes of bullet that's
what daniel was highlighting saying that's where
young christoph duda has his biggest advantage and
we'll need to see if he can keep that up against
someone who is as strong as wesley so of course
if there is a tie we get into the tie breaks of
the mini match four games at one plus one and
donya of course when these top players face off
they just want to crush an elite opponent but
there's quite a lot of prize money at stake and
in round two the winner gets a cool three grand
in addition to splitting the other
three grand based on win percentage so
a lot of money out at play here i'm i'm looking
at these prizes these are these are mouth-watering
and uh of course we should point out that even
when the match is decided there's uh quite a bit
left to be decided by the actual outcome of the
game so there's pride on the line uh there is a
lot of money on the line and this just adds to the
suspense and the excitement but just because of
the players themselves uh we get a big portion
of the of the excitement that comes with these
matches certainly the case and you know not only
are these players playing for quite a prize fund
that everybody who's watching can get involved and
try to win some cash guess the move right you want
to bust the move guess the move and there have
been some repeat winners that i've noticed in some
of these matches but you can get involved by going
to chess.com live trying to your hand and guessing
the correct moves of the players make them and the
top three premium gestures won cash prizes well
if you're not premium member you can win some
premium memberships it's a great opportunity to
test your hand at playing like some of the
world's best while having the incentive to win
some cool hard cash robert i'm looking at
the bracket here who are these weak players
yeah could they have found anybody stronger but
in all seriousness this is incredible look at
all of these players mvl aronian uh chess.com
could not have assembled a more elite squad of
uh blitz bullet and of course
classical players this is awesome
well before we get to this specific matchup dania
while i have you i have to ask look at his bracket
real quick and i'm going to make you pick the
winners of this matchup this is this round
except me robert this round pick your winners at
this round i really miss commentating with you
i was thinking that until you asked me to make
the prediction but i guess i have to stay true
to my nickname well we have the probability at
57 percent for wesley i think it's going to be a
close match i think it's going to come down to the
bullet but i think with duda's recent improvement
in the bullet section i have a feeling that he
might make a statement in that final section
now this is absolutely no disrespect to my boy
wesley i have tremendous respect for him he is
he's a monster there's just no other way to say it
i think this is going to be a very close match but
judah's recent improvement that might be
uh the game deciding phenomenon we'll see
well you know you're mentioning it we have the
smarter chess predictions i have to fight those
typically but right now i'm more or less
in agreement with it i am sort of upset
hearing myself say those words but look at
wesley so's blitz rating he's above 3 100 and
let's be real you add the increment to the clock
he's even stronger but to jkd's credit he was
really a force against fabiano caruana he started
off slowly he was down three games to none and you
know while i had the call i was kind of like wait
are these predictions can they be real dude is in
big trouble then he went off and won four straight
games to close that the longest time control
before being completely dominant in the shortest
time patrol he beat fabiano caruana eight games to
one in bullets oh that is that is incredible
now fabi of course is known for his playing
longer time controls but let's let's be real 8-1
against a player this elite in any time control is
uh a an achievement to be very proud of and
i have a feeling robert that the reason you
seem to imply that you're going with wesley here
i don't think it's because of the smarter chess
predictions i think it's because i called it for
duda if i'd called it for wesley i have a feeling
you would have cited against the smarter chess
predictions you know donya i i think i'm very
agreeable and i'll remove my arrow because i was
having some fun on the analysis board just before
but i you know i don't want to go against you
you're my friend we get along well i always enjoy
commentating with you but i think we have to give
based on the history and speed chess championship
and just how strong wesley so is and i think one
of the best parts about wesley is it doesn't feel
like he's tiltable in the same way others are
he is a stoic player and his style i think is
one that doesn't allow him to fully tilt now i
will say that if he is facing a deficit i don't
always believe that his style helps him mount a
comeback because it's a very precise style he's
not taking as much risk as other players but if he
starts out in the lead good luck taking him down
he's a boa constrictor he he's so universal he can
play a lot of different openings so i i agree with
you i think the sort of one could cite the lack
of this kind of absolute uncompromising play but
the flip side of that is is that he can play any
type of position he calculates incredibly well and
as you said he almost never tilts he's so calm
he's so experienced and for that matter duda is
uh to some degree as well i really haven't seen
him had that you know explosive tilt uh either so
uh we'll see if if either player manages to jump
out uh to a big lead at the start but as we saw in
the caruana match anything can be surmounted in
the sec for sure and we will be able to see the
action unfold in just a second the players getting
situated you see jkd stretching and we are off the
games are officially underway wesley so starts
with the white pieces we get a sicilian diana i'm
zero percent surprised about the opening because
i just saw young christophe duda use this against
fabiano caruana game after game and i remember jkd
playing this uh as far back as i remember how the
under 18 world youth i think the under when i was
playing the under 14 i think he might have been
playing the under 10 and he was already playing
the night or this guy is an expert in the truest
sense of the word in the night or but knight
c6 now am i hallucinating or is this a very
uncommon way to develop the knight in the night
or yeah and i think knight a5 this i have not seen
i guess the knight's going to c4 well if you
allow me my knight will gladly hop right in here
with the bishop's defense and actually he'll he'd
like to see maybe knight c4 knight c5 i've seen
that's an old school idea exploiting that pin
against the d6 pawn to situate the knight on c5
right you're saying that there is a queen in line
with the rook so the rook wins that battle most
of the time so knight c5 is possible here but duda
goes for it anyway and danya i think this goes to
show that allowing a capture on e6 and replacing
with a pawn that's typically not the biggest deal
because you're trying to fight tooth and nail for
that d5 square right exactly that plays right into
blacks and it's important to recognize the rules
for determining pawn structures in the night or
as you hinted at robert are completely different
you're fighting really over squares here and it's
not about the aesthetic appeal of your pawns and
that's why we see wesley sliding his bishop away
the fight over the d5 square is on and don't
i have to say that i like the knight of c4 a
lot better than i would if it were on d7 i'm just
going to drag the piece over the square which is
where it goes often you go knight d7 you bring
a rook to c8 you bring your bishop to e7 very
calm sort of natural developing moves
no huge risk in the early stages
but i like this knight on c4 because watch out
for a potential sacrifice on b2 of course not
right now you have to line up some pressure on the
knight on c3 with the rook on c and all that good
stuff but i see a knight on c4 i i just store
that information knight takes b2 at some point
may be a possibility maybe slide the queen away
to e1 and try to capture that knight before it
wreaks any havoc on the position because if you
play queen f2 here you might come under some
knight take c4 business instead wesley sliding his
king over so rook c8 the kind of move that would
be conducive to an idea that you mentioned robert
but i feel like wesley's holding this in store
uh the idea of of going queen e1 and taking on
c4 knight takes c4 here needs to be calculated
no it doesn't work because of queen e4
so duda does put something on the c file
yeah i actually want to bring up the analysis
board and show what dania was talking about
it's a very good point when you see a bishop
like here in line with another bishop right
these bishops are staring each other down you have
to watch out for tactics so for example if this uh
queen went to f2 at some point let's say here
you have to just look is there a knight g4
type of move opening up the bishop's attack on one
another and hitting the queen on f2 so those ideas
are all in the air and diana pointed out
correctly instead we saw queen e1 which
was donnie's move and taking on c4 let me ask you
now the b file is open how much do you like the
fact that you were able to take this knight off
the board yeah i don't know i mean one of white's
classical ideas here it's called knight d2 knight
f1 knight e3 but i also want a filet mignon steak
from ruth's chris steakhouse right now and i'm not
gonna get it so dude i might have something to say
about this by putting a rook on b8 and maybe a
queen on b7 uh and the the issue is that wesley
has to be very careful about how he defends the
b2 pawn if he goes b3 dude is going to sack on
b3 and checkmate him maybe he wants to drop his
bishop back to c1 but that entails it's that that
has its own problems maybe d5 uh this gets very
double-edged yeah and yeah i saw the eval bar just
jump in dude his favor and we'll like just sit
on the position for a moment here we'll kind
of think about it from a broader point of view and
daniel this knight went to f1 like you said trying
to get to e3 into this d5 square if we talk about
ideal strategy white would love to take on f6 and
then immediately put this knight on to the d5
square and play knight against bishop you often
hear bishops are better than knights but not when
the knight has a clear outpost and a knight on d5
against a dark square bishop means that the knight
is going to be the superior piece but that is
several moves away and as you just pointed
out dania moves like queen to b7 and then
maybe even an eventual d5 you always have to be
on the lookout for this d5 move it's critical in
the sicilian and if this bishop can land on a3 to
increase the pressure down the b file that would
be a big problem right and duda realizes that the
d5 square is in everything because even if wesley
positions a knight on d5 say knight e to d5 and
duda takes it with his knight he's gonna have the
idea of going bishop to g5 trying to distract that
bishop on c1 from its critical role that bishop on
c1 it's like atlas it's holding the world on its
shoulders and if judah can distract it that could
lead to some major problems with the b2 pawn
so i would consider knight t7 in this position
uh trying to include the knight in the attack
maybe also 98 knight c7 but opening up that line
of negotiation between the dark square bishop
and the g5 square instead due to going full on
frontal assault getting the rook to b6 all right
yeah this is a he makes his intentions very clear
i'm tripling i am going to sack on b2 if
you allow me for mate and a big issue as
you highlighted earlier is b3 is not a possibility
for white because you do have two pawns protecting
the square but i also have a bishop in prime
location to just sacrifice itself on b3 so
when i play rook b6 you'll have to find another
way to defend b2 and knight a4 will not satisfy
white's position because after rook b6 also have
rook to b4 just trying to kick this knight out so
already i believe wesley's in for a tough
decision he plays knight into d5 but what if
you just capture it like you said and then swing
a rook to b6 and try to get that g5 well i guess
maybe he wants bishop takes d5 ed and then rook
b6 he wants to take on c4 so duda keeping the
tension instead with bishop to d8 um okay so i
guess what if wesley plays g5 here or something
to that effect i i think i'm trying to figure
out i'm trying to get a pulse on the position
what does dude want to do maybe he just wants to
leave the knight on d5 entirely just go knight d7
that's that's i don't know an idea you mentioned
before and well wesley doesn't allow it to begin
with but knight d5 is met by bishop g5 you
pointed out this idea earlier yeah but maybe
on the other hand rook b6 is going to be met
with queen c3 he goes queen c3 preemptively
but that queen could also be a sitting duck
if let's say bishop could land on a5 and that
square could be supported somehow so maybe queen
b5 and bishop d a bishop a5 something like that
it's a bit of a trek to make this all work but
it's good to think in these terms of how do i
improve my bishop or the bishop one of six staring
into its own pawn the best move for black is pawn
e5 thrown off board and then that's that yeah if
only we could imagine how much that would change
chess you just said hate one of your own pieces
let's get that out the way because my bishop on f6
or bishop takes e5 that would be a great move
well isn't that a new variant you can capture
i was gonna say i think i heard about that uh and
but you could also do that over the over the board
just kind of pretending you know i'm doing you
a favor for god's sake i'm taking my own pieces
now wow c3 here is a very tempting move but then
wesley could play b3 and uh that pawn on b3 is
significantly more solid than it would be with
a pawn on c4 right this is really heating i mean
this is just like a pressure cooker in here it
doesn't seem like that much is happening but the
stakes are incredibly high for both sides in this
position you're mentioning pressure cookers you're
mentioning steaks are you hungry danya like what's
going on here no i got some granola here and some
coffee you don't have to worry about me uh robert
i got all the best uh food that the bay area has
to offer i i worry because i care done just so you
know i i know you i care about you too robert just
as we look at this incredibly tense position i i
need to waste everyone's time and just say this
robert needs that uh words of affirmation those
are important indeed and finally a knight on d5
he needed it because otherwise that bishop was
coming to c5 where the queen gets strapped over
here okay so can do to get his bishop to one
of these golden squares b4 oh and if he moves
it by the way 97 check has to be reckoned with
that's a fork and then d6 is going to topple
look at the time also 30 seconds i feel like
duda has let's go maybe rook c4 tries to get
his a pawn in motion wesley's position not easy
either it's not clear how to make progress here
do you like that what's pawn a4 i like that rook
c4 idea as well because you're trying to trap the
queen but the d6 pawn will be hanging so also dude
down to 30 seconds as well as he's been playing
you can't win good positions if we consider his
position good now without time on the clock and
down to 27 seconds and now he's sort of on the
defensive right donna he put his rooks on the c
file where they're not barreling through they're
just protecting the pawn that's gone too far
yes and h6 he hasn't forgotten about the idea of
bishop g5 wesley could drop his knight back at
some point and go after the d6 but i wouldn't do
that yet i would try to make more improvements to
my position but that's very hard to do in this
in this atmosphere maybe bishop e3 queen c1 try
to retool your pieces the problem is if you fall
asleep due to plays a4 and then the attack has is
reinvigorated so it's it's a very hard environment
to make any sorts of improvements uh the players
are at a standstill here h3 king h7 both trying
to make small improvements in the position and
wesley strikes with a four so i like k7 for the
end game but f4 is dangerous because if some
pieces get traded off i look at that e4 pawn it's
isolated it can be attacked but for now before
here comes the uh d6 uh pawn is weak and the
versus the d-file who's this easier to play for i
have no idea actually have no idea i think on one
hand black because black can make the attacking
moves but his position is kind of collapsing too
he's got eight seconds gotta move a4 maybe just to
add some tabasco sauce to that queen side he does
it he gives up the b-force but bishop b7 by wesley
maybe to take some pieces off the board while
he has a chance the problem is the a-file though
if it gets opened duda can double on that file
and deliver a lobster pincer mate sort of on a1
yeah that's a good call and you can't take on a4
like you would in other variations because the
bishop is now under attacking queen b4 offering
the queen trade just sliding the queen back
watch out for a b bishop d5 rook b6 all these
type of attacking moves and look at the clock
wesley under 15 seconds now retreating moves a
b and rook a8 he's got something to the a file
yeah he's he nervously plays bishop five and tri
okay okay eight queen oh we need two queen 255 g5
that's gonna be he does this first still
93 back but queen a2 for sure wesley and
the last he's got to move two seconds oh my
god he attacks the knight first trying to get
it out bishop d4 they'll be queen eighteen
twenty two playing with a three bishop e3
oh it was amazing oh my goodness wesley's a
devil is there three is gonna move he wants he
wants to take but the king runs away and bishop
three does nothing just take it rookie three oh
okay queen c7 watch out for h2 he's not over here
it almost works h5 he wants to play h5 and up and
up oh i don't like that movie i don't like e5
and a lot of lights battery f4 dude i had also
but this is looking good for black all of a sudden
take a g4 oh you can't go he's not doing it he's
got zero he's how do we get the move off i don't
understand this is unbelievable action to this
first game queen 266 battery back up e6 opens it
up that's correct but now dude has stabilized it
and don't blunder g7 with me right that's the
only thing and black despite being down a pawn
is better queen d6 and h4 i agree with oh but he
allowed g6 now that's a okay finally an end game
of course who's better white seven pawn though
no pawn take on g6 now activity for black rock
h7 life looks might be winning rook g2 mission
b3 and then f2 check oh okay he's got to get a
spawn in motion how do you get the 55 defending
c6 wesley's got to push it okay rooks he never
works he doesn't work register's only moved to
rookie it is not possible wesley's got to make
a move that is huge he wins the pawn and now
blacks are pumping this might be a draw though
g2 i feel like we're auctioneers here and then
right now as well what happened it's going to be
a split king e3 and how do you make a fortress
well either side could still blunder a bishop
or move the bishop accidentally g6 judo is
going to try to win this he's going to try
to get his rook to the other side of the board
robert he's going to try to deliver a side check
and get that kink pry it away from the bishop
but it's not easy to do that don't get made it
bishop d4 was almost made but that's why i
think wesley's been really smart but putting
his king on f4 that way wherever the rook goes
the king goes to the opposite side let me tell
you their hands are shake mine are and there's
r too when you're moving the mouse it's like
you don't want a mouse slip here you know it
looks like i'm getting super red uh looking
at this game but i think that just my camera
is doing funny things so i'm pretty calm right
now honestly i've been enjoying the action i'm
feeling really at home in my chair though this is
this is amazing and let's not forget this is the
first game we could not have asked for a better
opening salvo to this uh to this incredible match
and they're still going i mean they're trying to
you know posturing here but realistically
black just doesn't have any attempts even
the defense is very easy with that increment
particularly but i think that jkd is smart
to play this on we talk about how in the bullet
portion that's where he has his best chances he's
also up a pawn so even if this were a classical
game why not play it on he's a bishop yeah the
bishop on h5 is defended and defends everything
there's no risk okay they finally mentioned
but yeah and people shouldn't dismiss this and
ah you know he's just being obnoxious no he's not
he's wearing wesley dowd he's forcing him to find
all these defensive moves uh and he's as you said
uh the shorter the time control i think the more
it favors duda and in the second game we see the
players taking a breath time for a petrov not that
it's a peaceful opening the petrov can explode
yeah um i would i would say that from that first
game as i'm reflecting on it before we get into
the the middle of this one with the petrov and
pieces traded off but i will say that westley
put amazing defense together and for jan kristoff
in time trouble the fact that he was able to
get what looked like an attack he couldn't
quite handle it he didn't put it together
perfectly but his mouth speed was there so that
bodes well for his chances come bullet time
wow g3 king g2 i thought that might have been a
mouse slip but i suppose not i don't know that
looks a little bit suspicious of that file getting
up and now you mentioned the petrov yesterday
on my stream i was actually checking out the
original book by russian master alexander petrov
after whom the opening is named in the early
1800s he authored i think the very first chess
book ever written in the russian language and
it's available in fully digitized form online and
it was just fascinating to read how uh no even
proper chess notation didn't really exist uh at
the time what a legacy that this guy left on the
game now wesley and dude are playing the opening
uh named after him yeah some people call it
legacy others call it misery because trying to
beat the petra from the white side it's been a
task that players have struggled with for a very
long time interesting because in russian people
don't really say petrov they say russian game
yes but in other languages you mostly say petra
you don't say russian game but in in uh russian
you also say spanish game for rye lopez you never
really say rai lopez just an interesting little
tidbit although i guess in english these days
we just called the spanish right like i always
called the rai i mean i'm one of the cool guys
i'm also kind of you know one of those you know
we'll talk back to the chest back in the chest
back to the chest but we've got a position that's
a little bit symmetrical well no g pawns here and
donna you made a comment earlier which is a very
smart one that taking away from the center opened
up the rook on that faith the problem is come end
game time or middle game time those pawns can be
targets and in particular this part on g6 now but
wesley is using the f file to his advantage
how do you weigh that when you're assessing
this position donya do you prefer white's open f
file because i certainly prefer the pawn structure
for white rather than the file for black now
normally i prioritize peace placement but the
thing is here duda can trade on e8 and go rookie
one so i kind of agree with you and then you
can situate a rook on e3 the problem is you know
people talk about the principle of two weaknesses
uh you know oftentimes it's not enough to have
one weakness you gotta create another one but
i think it's also worthwhile to think about it
from the other side principle of two strengths
it's often not enough to have one main asset
in your position such as an open file because
the opponent can adjust to that you sort of need
two distinct areas of the border factors where
you are superior and here we only see one and duda
is nicely adjusting to it by over protecting that
knight on f3 pawn on f2 is protected so i think
he's got tiny pull but wesley shouldn't have
really any problems uh holding this particularly
with that nice time advantage he's built
and i was about to say that judo is probably
going to take with the pawn e3 to take advantage
of the pawn structure because look at this
position black has three pawns to whites two
but because white's pawns are undoubled and black
spawns are creating a pass pawn is not really
possible unfortunately you have these double pawns
and that's the downside of the dull pawns plus
side another open file downside hard to create
past pawns in end game so that is why duda took
towards the center because if you cut the board
at the e file white has a five on four from a to e
and black has a three on two output in quotes
because they're not creating a past pawn so what
white wants to do is trade off all the pieces
go to a king and pawn end game and then play e4
and have a four on three advantage you essentially
have an extra pawn in king and pawn end game terms
that's a great explanation um could not have
said it any better myself and and that's
always something people forget to do i think is
is sort of prognosticate okay what happens if this
piece is removed from the port what happens if we
have a pawn end game and wait i'm getting a call
oh the robert has anti-compliments yeah i wasn't
supposed to oh sorry okay i'm off the commentary
but the committee for not complimenting robert has
just gave me a call but i'll talk to them later
and here we see wesley getting the knight to f5 so
he's adding some heat to the position robert and
it has to be pointed out that with these three
pieces on the board an attack is not out of the
question tactics related to white's king are not
out of the question and have to be considered
yeah the main problem i would say though after
knight to five which is right that there's maybe
even a sacrifice later on h4 this knight can just
hop into e5 where it closes down the queen from e3
and importantly i'm just going to show this very
quickly it's uh just a simple sort of tactical
idea is that if i can say put my queen to c2
with check or if i can just run my queen over
c2 you'll take me oh free queen then i have knight
takes e3 maneuvers so distracting the white queen
is very much in play because the e3 square may be
too much of a target to keep an eye on yeah and
and look at wesley now poking and prodding at dude
as uh center c5 trying to undermine the knights
let me tell you that this is getting very
concerning with all of this all of the stuff
that duda has to keep together maybe queen e4
what is wesley threatening exactly i'm not sure
but it just feels like there's tactics in the
air b5 is an idea involving that other pawn
you mentioned the second rank a2 cool it's
not easy to keep white's position together and
that's the good sign of having this double pawn
on g6 is your king can kind of have a shield if it
gets to the square whereas without this f2 pawn
white's king feels a little bit more iffy and so
a lot to consider here for wesley he's also
uh next enough was it for a younger student
and duda is down quite a lot of time for the
second game in a row but uh maybe he should put
the griffin i don't really care when i'm down on
the clock but this is a very concerning position
but okay let's see what he does and in fact d5
has been played and things start to fall apart
here for uh jan shishtoff i would be worried about
his position for sure because now c4 is directly
under attack you take on b5 you have to watch
out for the a2 pawn how do you even continue here
but this is the kind of yeah d5 that
knight on e5 is what concerned him
he puts a rook on a four he's trying to sort of
you know assume that defensive stance but bc is
possible then maybe he wants d5 oh i don't
know and that actually would be the ideal
in terms of pawn structure situation if you could
allow you allowed the capture on c4 played d5
because then black's queen side pawns will not be
connected as we head closer and closer to an end
game and he does take there so d5 didn't yeah
don't take on d5 because we take d5 check i i
thought maybe black should put his king on h7 wait
nights it's a fork oh just kidding you're in check
right exactly that's the whole problem okay
so now wesley has to find maybe queen b6 uh to
open up that avenue to b2 but then duda could
take on c4 with a knight to cover that square
so again this is really heated up and
what's really good for wesley's got the time
to really think through this critical moment but
i'm not sure he's got a great solution to this
it's the transition that he's not going to be very
thrilled about because white towards the end game
has now two unopposed past pawns the double pawns
we've talked about those enough for now and the
isolated pawns and the queen set are going to be
a bad thing it's hard to push them when they're
not connected you know i have the feeling that
judah's position was really falling apart but it
just seems that he was in this move rook four he's
managed to stabilize it maybe queen okay queen e8
drops it back did you see me click on c6 just
there uh i did not i was watching through live
chess yeah i accidentally but touched the queen
and touched the c6 squad oh so you played queen
c6 yeah yeah wow that's that's awesome yeah and i
i think i'll never forget when rob the time that
robert had played queen c6 like queen 64 though
not only is the queen called the diagonal uh queen
a4 is just on the same diagonal yes i like i had
i was in the right path but daniel 82 is hanging
but queenie four queen takes g6 queen e4 king age
seven queen takes g6 and knight e5 wait what if
king f6 okay so if queenie said uh i think white
could have gone queen e6 check instead okay let's
uh go to the analysis board real quick okay h7
queen takes g6 wait what oh my god king f6 knight
g4 to save the knight and then you take through
anyway it's not important uh i i didn't mean to
derail us from the game because i was dude's got
[ __ ] sex now west is gonna do something similar
oh potentially you scared me rookie played
potentially queen takes c4 ideas in the air
but it didn't work just yet but now these
pawns starting to fall but the knight on f5
is undermined it is and the d-pawn is ready to
start rolling d67 coming to a theater near you
this is a really good one man yeah thanks anyway
so in a1 queen a1 i see your idea trying to get to
h1 over here very subtle but then rook f1 shuts
that down and i thought queen e5 for a second but
white's pieces are all perfectly placed except
for the front of h3 i don't think you want the
king on h3 but considering where black pieces are
the king is as safe as it will get yeah maybe you
want to go some crazy now that doesn't work i'm
thinking about all sorts of crazy ideas that's
one hallmark of 2700 plus chess uh which which
might be a sort of a banal observation but their
pieces are always so good i mean even black's
pieces are good uh the sort of superiority is
marginal but it's just enough to send black into
a tailspin and now wesley dipping below 30 seconds
i don't see a move i don't see a single resource
as of yet it's amazing that undermining the knight
and f5 just does so much damage the knight of c4
is great here and well protected the knight and f5
should be well protected by a pawn but that pawn's
being removed in 18 seconds counting down here
for wesley and jkd only has 7.6 himself but unless
he can't find a move he can't find a move and
who can blame him i mean neither can we five sec
okay queen anyone played rook f1 queen f6 maybe
ah this way no but d6 and then he said check
okay so he brings some of his pieces back
duda has to be careful here comes rook f7 and
steve queen d5 on top of that oh yeah 35 queen
at queen f7 also oh my goodness that's brutal
and he does it ready queen of fate made it over
we'll bring up the analysis board i just want
to show how the concluding touch could have been
really nice if queen takes f7 you can take either
way rook f8 stops the pawn but then i go d7 you
move your knight and i go d8 equals queen i give
up my one pawn and promote the second and that way
a rook here so that would be game over what a
display surgical precision by duda who again it
felt like wesley had that initiative going but uh
it was the structural deficiencies in his position
uh in the end that reigns supreme when studio was
able to stabilize the situation and he delivers
the first blow what a game and while we talked
about pawn structure in the last game we might
as well continue the trend that pawn on d4
is an isolated pawn now for now that's fine
white is going to castle and when you have an
isolated pawn the adjacent files are open you
want to put a work on c1 a rook on e1 great and
operate using that pawn to your advantage however
as we get later and later into the game and that
isolated pawn remains then i can try to attack
it because a pawn's best friend is another pawn
look at this pawn on e6 extremely well defended
thanks to a pawn f7 you're not attacking that
ever the pawn d4 has to be protected by pieces
which means that more of white's attention will
be uh forced on that square and that should allow
black to then start putting pressure and taking
advantage of that so danya it's still very early
you know these iqp i say the queen pone positions
very well how do you see this game going and which
side would you rather have here well i like
the two bishops uh and uh in the iqp we have to
watch for two things if we're looking at white's
position his potential to break through in the
center with d5 which absolves him of the weakness
and i'm not saying by the way he's going to
do that right now doesn't work because of 95 but
just what to watch for uh if you can get d5 in and
he can do so successfully he'll have all of the
advantages of his position and he rids himself of
the isolated pawn that's number one number two is
does white have attacking chances on the king side
that's what wesley is orienting himself toward
he's shifting his bishop to d3 that queen can
travel to h3 and uh it's impossible to give made
in one fell swoop you often want to provoke a
weakness such as g6 or h6 that in turn creates an
anchor or a weakness on f6 or a pawn that you can
sacrifice your bishop on uh but you have to do all
of this while negotiating and buying yourself time
in regards to that isolated pawn which judah will
pile up on while making other improvements in his
position i like white's position rook a d1 maybe
but wesley's also got to be very very careful yeah
yeah rook 81 gives you the idea of later playing
d5 it also just defends the pawn and the bishop
can slide back to b1 for good measure so what
i'll say dania is and how we were kind of talking
about it is that for white you want to build up
attacking chances because your pawn structure
is worse so you know that if you don't get that
attack and let's say the queens come off the board
then black is much happier right because you have
this i said pawn so what black ideally does is say
hey it's a it's a fair trade queen versus queen
let's just get these two off the board right now
and then i'm going to blockade and then attack
your pawn so a very common idea for black
is to bring a knight to d5 and say your pawn's
not moving and meanwhile well now you're clearly
threatening things with the bishop on the diagonal
but you were trying to start trading some pieces
and then later in the game go after that yeah
and as you were explaining i was looking at
the shelf behind me i used to well i think i
still have it but i can't find it a book by
a grandmaster alexander baburin who uh i
think lives in ireland now originally of
course russian and he wrote an entire book on pawn
structures but most of it was focused on the iqp
and i remember really liking that book uh
and then i remember a facebook post i think
this was a year or so ago and i think this just
happens on amazon when a book is out of print
uh but somebody posted a baburn's book i
think it's called winning pawn structures
was listed at 900 a pop or something like
that man if you want to understand the iqp
you gotta you gotta shell out you gotta buy iqp
insurance or something to cover part of that well
played there and yeah the iqp it's and it can be
an expensive pawn so you know that makes sense
the book would also be pricey and knight takes d4
would also be pricey let me tell you oh let's see
i'll show that tactic very quickly here the
point is that there's a rook there will be
a queen the rook wins that battle and you are
able to take on each of them with check to boot
opening up an attack on the queen that just wins
the game uh by winning black's queen directly
so that's not something you can capture yet
i could see a rook d7 move in the future that
puts more pressure on d4 g5 idea mission pc5 is
gonna be very nasty though you're absolutely right
all right bishop g5 threatening the h7 pawn
and h6 i know you've done it you're gonna
sacrifice or try to on that square but whenever
there's an h6 and a sacrifice there you have to
be sure that it amounts to something now often
in these positions white can store a draw by uh
okay let's just show this let's put the
analysis board and show these kind of ideas
where let's say uh in the movie go rook d7
bishop g5 just to go through with this that
if we get a position like this right
we have a check back and forth exactly
so that's important because otherwise the
move like rook takes d4 would be a big problem
for white in many regards but you can at the very
least go back and forth and make a draw so you
say then it's worth diving even more deeply into
this and now that you see the draw you put that
in your back pocket and say where is more the
eval bars is plus one there must be something
in white's favor it's your lucky coin not in
your pocket anywhere anywhere but your pocket
do you know what do you know what movie that's
from all right javier you know calm yourselves
pretty good it's your old coin what do you make
of this d5 move that's a actually a very thematic
sacrifice now this looks like madness he's putting
his pawn where it can be taken by 884 pieces but
the reality is knight on f6 cannot move if he
takes with a pawn then yes wesley has sacked
upon but he can position that bishop on e3 to d4
centralizing it and targeting the knight on f6
he's got tremendous compensation both positionally
and tactically so due to trying to takes for the
knight uh and after knight takes he'll probably
take with a bishop again taking the queen results
in a discovery uh but maybe wesley still goes
bishop d4 i don't think that he's got uh you
know massive compensation but this just seems a
lot more pleasant bishop g5 by the way is still
possible and there's a new wrinkle to this now
that the position has opened up a little bit so
this is scary for black i really i'm starting to
like black's position i'm not quite believing in
the attack the way that you seem to be and that
could just be me having some oversight saying ah
you know whatever i you know i like sacrificing
people's pieces so uh something about this doesn't
quite feel like the attack is as strong as it
wants to be but i also completely understand
what you're saying either bishop d4 bishop g5
and pile up on h7 or if you play h6 go for the
sacrifice so that's really what this all comes
down to and dude it might take with the pawn
on d5 and no okay never mind i just can't get over
the i think some people thought i lost my mind and
didn't realize it was a reference and here we're
going to see a reference to bishop takes h6 there
we have it and again he does have that draw in
his pocket i think i don't think duda can do
anything about it maybe rookie 8 actually rookie
8 can be a very annoying resource oh but he goes
and said for queen e7 and the bar just freaked
out so i don't like that i think rookie a might
have been actually a very serious resource so
you're trying to make space for the king and
eventually to run away yeah that's exactly
what i'm doing that move wasn't liked either so
what do you think what's going on here why did
it go plus two points and let's bring up the
analysis board so we can try to figure this
out it went plus two about to then back to
equal after the very natural rookie one move
which is trying to get rookie through rook g3
what does black do with rookie five bishop
b4 i wonder you know donya i get the feeling
that i know what's happening here so let's
see if rook's here there could be a problem
down the d file in some of these variations so
i believe the superior option was rook d-e-1
the most counter-intuitive move ever
because you want to bring another attacker
there's no bishop before in the end
wow that's that is actually awesome
detective work robert well i see i see the
eval right and that's what's leading me to the
conclusion is that you're saying bishop e4 there's
a problem with the rook hanging on d1 so dania
how do we make these work in our own games rather
than just using an eva bar to get the answer
it's difficult and i mean this everybody can
appreciate the subtlety of this the finesse
required to perceive this in advance that's part
of the reason chess is such a magical game the
game goes down to these tiny moments and at
the end of the day it's all about undefended
pieces lpdo loose pieces drop off one of my
favorite shorthands uh that is a very helpful
thing to remind yourself of every single time
you have a piece undefended by any other pieces
particularly one that's on the first rank that
is a liability and uh you know it's not that you
want to eliminate those pieces actively but
when you have one of those pieces that opens
up the potential for for tactics and uh this
is hard to see because it's so natural right
who would play rook d one and leave the
other rook on f1 to do absolutely nothing
uh and yet everything comes down to concrete
properties of the position when you are attacking
the rules of engagement are different than when
you're just trying to improve all of your pieces
and what a lovely move rook c5 just trying to get
rid of this attacker which is of course going to
g5 at some moment so rook c5 says you go to
g5 though i'll take you and queen g5 is that
a drawer's black i always control i can drop my
bishop to g6 so i need to think about the right
configuration right because you still can't
take me on g6 with your bishop with a rook
hang with check but i'm not positive i'm just not
throwing in ideas and for everybody who's watching
that rook de1 move i would not find that in
a blitz game myself i just saw the eval bar
rook fe1 looks logical oh wait now i'm looking at
rook d8 is the response here is where things can
improve and i should again look at that rook on
d1 it is really burning wesley right now i think
he recognizes it he i think he's losing this
and his clock is burning too ten seconds under
things for both players he's got to trade pieces
and okay but now rook takes [ __ ] king takes g8
okay it's not over yet he's got two let's not
forget he's got oh he's got only one pawn for
the piece he got it one second one second oh my
gosh he barely got that move off barely rook d5
is possible here what am i doing he's going to
move he's got some time and westy shakes his head
he just but even in the end i mean he could have
tried but uh at that point duda had consolidated
two points ahead look at this performance in the
early going by jkd incredible defense a chance
missed by wesley but as you pointed out robert
that is so hard to see now this is just something
that when you have the eval bar on you see that
rook f21 is zeros and but it was almost plus two
hey now you have to think outside the box a
little bit i'm going to store that one i'm gonna
write that down later to uh use in future lessons
because rook d e one what a clever way to go for
and dania this opening that we have now in game
four wesley shows pawns well advanced in front
of his castle's king that can backfire but it
also can use to restrict the pieces for instance
we see a bishop on g3 we know that's not the best
bishop because all of these pawns on the dark
squares make it uh pretty useless on the diagonal
but how do you feel about these positions i think
that the light squares in particular f5 in the
future could be a problem but i now pass it over
to you because you're gonna be able to explain
this better well i play this with black uh and
and the italian is the kind of opening of course
it was all the rage in you know the 1700s uh my
voyage gioquino graco and all those early masters
and then there was a period when people sort of
at the highest level switched to the ray lopez and
now it's all the rage again because it's it's a
very rich opening it's a very hard to understand
opening there's a lot of subtle ideas now
of course uh square on f5 robert is very weak
white can strike in the center with d4 and black's
position can collapse very quickly on the other
hand black has very specific ideas in relation to
it's sort of blitz in in in football right you're
rushing the quarterback if he gets the pass off
okay he's probably going to find a receiver
downfield but he might get sacked and the
equivalent of that is h5 h4 ideas f5 ideas black
is going to try to mount that blitz before white
gets his knight to e3 and plays d4 is he going to
manage to do that that's why he played knight g8
he's trying to open up the passage for that f1
here we see it will do to be able to respond to
this precisely right and if he gets d foreign
not only can he avoid a concussion but he can
cause some harm to his opponent so uh this is a
position where black is in some danger of having
pushed too far overextended on the king side which
is the nature of the way you play this opening for
from wesley's perspective and for jkd another
decision do i take with the rook or do i take with
the pawn if he takes with the pawn he has to think
about e4 as a possibility at some point for black
saying your pawn e3 will be a weakness rather
than a strength and if he takes to the rook
he has to look at this rook on f8 as is that a
strong rook or what is it just looking good in
a semi-open file so now the file is fully open i
was just checking to see the last year in which
the new york giants won a game uh but my research
failed me mm-hmm but i mean the giants have won
three games this year and just so you know i grew
up as a jets fan and just have one zero games so
man i'm well i grew up as a 49ers fan so i share
in the plights but in any case are we supposed to
be compensating chess or is this you're the one
who made the unnecessary football results usually
it's sports that makes a oh it's a stalemate
out there and i'm always like you know stalemate
the game is over right so it's not a stalemate
right like i just want all announcers in sports
if somebody sends us them just so they know when
they call the middle of a game a stalemate because
neither side is making progress that's not
a stalemate just the game continues the rant
uh completely on the same page to continue right
when somebody let's tell al michaels and all the
john madden oh bill belichick and jim harbaugh
are engaged in a chess match here it's gonna be
a real chess match they're gonna try to check me
that doesn't tell anything about anything that's
happening this is the most generically used term
uh in in sports coverage ever but well how would
you feel if they were like they're engaged in zuk
suang right now you'd be like wait what what's
going on here like imagine they use that correctly
you know i do appreciate it when chess is used but
uh it's interesting that you know these
terms stalemate and checkmate have made
it out into sort of the common sports comparison
vocabulary i don't know it's just interesting but
wesley's the one trying to deliver trackmate
here i don't think he's going to succeed
um yeah i know i don't think so either but the 994
does look very good the bishop one h2 still does
not look particularly promising but what jkd is
holding on hope for is d4 you mentioned this idea
it is thematic in the white side of the italian
game can i get d4 in and break open the position
but west is just creating many problems along this
f file where he has just better control yeah and
here comes the doubling on the f phone and what
has he managed to do here what he's managed to do
has been to sort of close off the center minimize
the impact of white's pluses and maximize the
impact of his own pluses in particular that
knight on f4 incredibly strong it can be replaced
by a rook should it be captured uh he's definitely
better here this is a big chance for him bishop h5
what duda can try to do here is move the knight
away from f3 and basically say okay we're at a
stalemate come at me bro because i've got that
bishop on h2 assuming that defensive role putting
the brakes on any potential g4 mode because that
weakens and softens up that f4 knight which can
be captured so that was that was very well played
done yeah that was extremely well done um you're
right though that if you can move the knight let's
say knight g1 play g3 even though it makes your
bishop look not very good on h2 for the time
being if you could trade off most of the heavy
pieces you're not getting yourself in any trouble
and for wesley how does he actually increase the
pressure here he says my knight and c6 let's just
go back a half step knight c6 dominated by a pawn
three squares away let me reroute that piece
and knight to g1 so he's trying to get g3 in
yeah sorry and i just found out klay thompson
had achilles okay i'm kind of devastated but
anyways uh that was my turn yesterday i'm
sorry i did not hear that i this is just the
first time hearing about it g3 would be a big
blunder though knight takes d3 is a problem now
yeah so bishop c2 okay back to the game what dude
is trying to do is shore up all of his potential
weaknesses that bishop on c2 we say the bad
bishops defend ooh and g3 that's a very committal
decision look at that bishop on h2 uh there have
been better bishops in the history of bishopdom
but the plus side of this is bad bishops defend
good pawns said romanian grandmaster mihai shuba
great chess author by the way and that pawn on g3
is fulfilling a crucial role it's covering the f4
square look at the knight on h5 it isn't too happy
either so wesley trying to find alternate ways
into white's position sacking the pawn to soften
up that e4 pawn yeah i think that black's vision
looks excellent because while white is holding off
black's pieces that's the best way to describe it
why is not attacking white is not threatening
anything there's nothing of consequence that black
needs to be on the lookout for in fact everything
that's weak in the position is what white has
to defend rather than the other way around and
look at this taking on the f file saying i can
control the f5 if i want the queen had to stay
put defending the e4 pawn and hey knight f6 wins
f6 yep knight f6 is going to be very nasty very
hard to deal with wesley trying to see queen f7
check if he can do that in a better way he can
he's going to take on c4 and he's gonna attack
e4 this is excellent work here in this middle game
by wesley patiently poking and prodding and then
seizing the opportunity will do to be
able to coordinate his defensive forces
this is looking pretty grim but i wouldn't rule it
out and i take c4 check nice he's going to lose i
mean bishop before queen e4 and some chances
there for white but should be losing i think
yeah the bishop is so weak on h2 and if you
play g4 i don't even have to go knight f4
but i can think about it so this bishop a bishop
three squares away from knight certainly dominates
it even more so than a pawn does the knight h5
clearly better than this bishop on h2 and black is
up upon better pieces more material and a minute
extra on the clock looks good for wesley's chances
yeah and knight f6 here is possible trying
to reroute the knight to g4 the newly created
weakness uh in general in the end game it's a good
idea to fully understand burying the bishop on
on h2 and the pawn on g3 is now a permanent
weakness it's a good idea whenever a pawn
is pushed to understand which weak squares have
been created that tells you a lot about how you
should position your pieces here for example
black now has the f3 square he can situate a
bishop there potentially uh he can also bring
i mean there's just so many attempts or b5
i just want to be careful when you push puns
not to trade too many of them so we'll see how
he plays this he is i mentioned robert yeah i'm
looking at the king you mentioned the f3 square
i was thinking the king could also try to get
into f3 oh absolutely there's room there for two
well no there's room there for one but the knight
on e4 pressuring g3 now i like the point you were
making about not trading too many pawns or at
least being aware of which pawns you should trade
because now oh yeah wins upon no not trading
points but then the ship c7 at the end
good call hmm how about so tricky i also want to
play d5 and then bishop b5 check but the problem
is you know we can analyze it later but nice if if
i take on um f1 which is one the king would have
taken on e4 so knight f6 in the end of that line
instead of bishop takes uh f1 oh so maybe we can
show that later yeah maybe d5 was good we're doing
that whole gm thing where we're just analyzing to
our own benefit and everybody has today what are
these fools discussing right now uh this pawn on
g3 remains weak but the knight and f1 stabilizing
that for the time being the bishop on b6
it was such a bad bishop before now it's doing
quite a good job on b6 stopping the b7 pawn
from moving and covering the length and diagonal
yeah and wesley's so good in these positions his
technical skill is basically unparalleled and
here comes the sun here comes d5 now bishop b5
trying to of course dislodging the knight from
f1 but 93 check and then the bishop assumes the
defensive role from e1 due to doing a great job
apportioning his limited resources the problem is
robert you called it i think the king is coming
in through e4 to f3 and that is going to be a
doomsday scenario for white is that king is going
to wreak absolute havoc on the defensive forces
the yeah big issue is the g3 pawn is a weakness
that can't be moved and you can't don't take on e3
i would go about and do that actually it
might not be so bad not king e3 and e4
usually you're too quick i think it's
winning but i wouldn't risk it and
he doesn't yeah that's definitely the safer play
here and the knight can come to f oh but there's
96 check what what i'm trying to highlight is
you don't really want to trade knights because
a single extra pawn in an opposite color bishop
and ending gives the side with the material
deficit good chances to hold so knight f5 along 96
would not be good instead of king of three giving
the e5 to win g3 and that gives you a nice pass
pawn and bishop d6 do the last ditch attempt but
that's pretty effective robert king takes g3 you
don't want to do because it would have lost the
knight instead setting his pawn in motion but now
the bishop from d6 guards g3 but he has a bigger
problem to worry about that's the e pawn and
knight f5 in the picture two seconds on the clock
he's not maybe not gonna get that out yeah it's
over and a great game a great recovery by wesley
taking a bite out of that early lead
winning with the black faces in an italian
that was a great game technically very precise and
you mentioned it he's very hard to tilt very hard
yeah right after losing uh two of the first three
games going down by a two and a half half score
you would think hey does he feel like he has to
win does he have to do something really impressive
he did push his pawns from his king but that was
part of a standard opening set up and then he went
forward from there and look at this game right
now we're in a territory where white has trade
off the queens even material but pawn structure is
not symmetrical and white is first to the threat
right bishop to b6 hits the rope this rook on d1
is attacking a bishop this rook is defending said
bishop and i'm not saying that black is in huge
danger but you have to know what you're doing
and there is an opportunity after rook d7 to play
move like knight c5 and potentially get the bishop
pair as we head in more towards the ending or play
move like c4 to kick the bishop it's a lot to work
out here if you are jk and this move rook g1 on
the sixth move of the night or is a move that uh
that basically has made a resurgence recently it
was really popularized by ivan chuck my research
tells me was first played in the year 1990 by the
yugoslavian international master goron todorovic
uh and it was played several times in the
early 90s popularized in the late 90s but
it's sort of been re-retooled in in recent years
after gary kasparov night off specialist made
a a dent in it so interesting to observe
the sort of uh opening fashions here and
like you said robert i think white's developed
some very unpleasant pressure here with bishop h3
ideas bishop c5 dude has got to keep his position
together he does indeed and not easy for him
clearly spending clock but that has been a theme
a trend i should say of the longest time patrol
duda is every single game down a minute on the
clock at least and right now no exception to
that he's down a full minute he still has plenty
of time right three minutes and 49 seconds for
blitz game pieces have been traded off but wesley
moving instantly so dania knight c5 played here
what to respond with i don't want to take you yeah
maybe you have to though takes in rook to i mean
at the very least you get rid of the immediate
initiative but you do acquiesce to the fact that
white has the two bishops uh what else is there
i mean if you move the bishop from e6 to let's
say f5 then well that paves the road for the
f1 bishop to jump out onto c4 so he does take
yeah and i like that decision and i also like
the follow-up king c7 because what was such a
thorn in black side was this bishop on b6 well no
b6 square for you in fact black if he zoo chooses
can eventually play b6 as you mentioned rook to
d8 is possible there's also i was going to say
h6 why does my rook need to go to a different file
instead of going to the open file directly let me
create an open file for my rook yeah then try to
make use of it and viking try to close that down
with a move g6 that of course creates its own
liabilities uh because such a change in pawn
structure is a very responsible decision right
black and play five or something but i'm leaning
toward g6 here i feel like allowing the opening
of the h file robert is something just feels a
little bit off about that i mean g takes h6 is
probably a draw but i think wesley's shooting
for more here he's definitely contemplating g6
will he play it i feel like he won't and what
let's just strike that on the record i just
wanted to prove that you would be right so
if i said something it's the opposite's going
to happen but the reason why i didn't like g6
and not h5 to follow is these pawns are closer
to where black's pieces are going to go and could
fall in the end game the reason i like them is
if you can imagine that the rooks get traded this
bishop obviously would come to f8 and then try to
get to the g7 pond there could be sacrifices that
allow this g-pawn to spring free very long story
but something to keep in the back of your mind
i am much more concerned about the h5 pawn than
i am about any of black's pawns that no i think
you you make a very fair point uh because for the
time being the rook on d8 is very stably holding
that that a fate square is what you really need
to watch for if a bishop lands there as you said
it's not going to be good the other thing to watch
for if the bishop from e3 eventually sacrifices on
h6 with that bishop being on e6 covering the
promotion square it's going to be very hard
to make that work but still something to watch
for and uh wesley deciding to keep that line of
uh negotiation of the f8 square open
maybe bring the bishop back to c5
but i like judah's activity here and i agree
with you robert i i have to say even though i
predicted the move i i'm beginning to lose uh
quite a bit of faith in in white's position
that rook on g1 really tied to its place
because bishop g4 should be such a disaster
that's certainly true and i'll add that the pawn
on g6 may look good but the pawn h5 does not so
it's very weird and typically we say that a pawns
you know a pawn chain is only as good as its base
the h5 pawn it is a bit difficult to get to it's
on a rook file that means it will take quite a bit
of energy to go after it but it's not that easy to
defend either and rook g3 played causing duda to
sit and think is there some kind of rook to the
queen side coming is there a c3 or c4 push that
will allow you to take advantage of your queenside
pawn majority i just like the placement of black's
pieces better look the knight and d4 bishop on e6
rook and d8 harmonious piece placement for duda
yeah i was just finalizing a pun
so hence my delayed response but
i'll share that maybe after the game
because i know it's going to make you cringe
but now the rook does he takes the plunge he says
all right i'm going to go for activity come hell
or high water by hook or by crook i'm going to
create some chances against the black king and
i actually really really like that particularly
in the context of the time situation he's got
a minute and a half extra and maybe something
like a4 to add heat to the position he doesn't
have a lot of time to spare robert because bishop
g4 let's not forget uh is a very big threat he's
got one or two tempe at the maximum yeah because
once h5 falls down and goes g6 but don't using b2
yes kv2 is certainly an idea and i was going
to say that your a4 idea may be giving up the
kingside pawns to win the queenside pawns then we
have a race and the bishops are very good in pawn
races because they can both defend the kingside
and also attack the side the bishop for example on
the d5 square would be able to threaten the corner
and defend the other ones so that's just why when
their pieces go on both sides of the board uh if
paul's bus says what i should say having bishops
is tends to be a good thing instead prophylaxis
by wesley playing f3 accepting new weaknesses but
stopping of course the bishop from coming
to g4 and duda says i won't be denied he's
getting his knights out for i don't something
with that move f3 seems a little off now wesley
seems passive again although he does he has shut
off the immediate line of attack to the h5 pawn
yeah and i was thinking rook c8 but i'm not
sure i want to go into the rookless ending
here uh trading off allows the bishops to shine
as king to b7 the rook c6 was the idea and here's
your a4 dominion it's starting to look more
promising for white you're actually creating
some legitimate threats and rook d5 well that
pawn is fulfilling a very important role of
guarding the c4 square which could be used as a
base for the bishop on f1 but the bishop on f1
could also move potentially to g2 duda wants to
shut that down with knight f4 in a timely manner
yeah actually now knight f4 is even stronger
and that's why the rook on d5 is nice because if
you take me on f4 i take with the e pawn i'm
opening up the fifth rank and the h5 pawn and
he's trying to exploit that diagonal f4 e takes
f4 would be a very bad blunder due to bishop g2
what is due to dude is he closed it down he does
with the bishop but f5 that was clever though
putting the bishop on e4 and f5 just puts another
pawn on a light square which i likely can go after
later in the game so or even immediately yeah
there it is no no it's an important decision
here for uh for wesley because if you take on e5
the rook takes and well thank you for giving me a
direct attack on your h5 pawn right i was thinking
some bishop g2 e4 rook d3 ideas i mean there are
some ideas down the long diagonal actually
rook d3 here is not out of the question oh
it is maybe yeah okay that's too much i i love it
i'm going to show it let's bring up the analysis
no no no i love it bishop d3 bishop g2 e4 daniel's
idea was if c takes now this pawn is pinned and if
you take with the rook thank you for your rook
with the check but of course black does not have
to take on d3 black and move the rook away for
example rook takes h5 and then b up in exchange
and move on from there so nice idea though the
tactics were almost working and instead we saw the
trade and we're seeing a repetition two times who
is the one declining the repetition or thinking
about declining and i'm not actually sure i think
it's wesley wesley bishop g2 would lead to a draw
i think he should yeah i think he should too he
doesn't have any other chances he might lose that
pawn otherwise right and this rook on e5 now
is superb and yeah he allows the wait it's not
draw it it is the draw okay that's a good decision
and we talked about this you know wesley realizes
he's the only down a point uh you don't want
to do anything crazy and just give up you know
another point uh because there's so much time
left in the match there's just no need for that
and wesley did just win that game with the black
pieces he goes right back to this line with the
early g5 it looks risky but wesley proved hey my
king does not actually get in as much trouble as
it could if i'm not careful so he were kg7 knight
g8 last time this is a great time to share my pun
because they are repeating uh the line from the
previous game we've already discussed it i'm
all here what did the swedish grand master say
when he came up with a good move i have an ikea
oh my gosh there was a
reason i thought of this but
uh the reason is way too elaborate to talk about
talk about the position i'm in all right all right
all right i'll talk about the position now uh so
what's going on okay that was actually pretty okay
i can guarantee a lot of people are laughing we've
got over 10 000 well over 10 000 people and by the
way a huge shout out to everybody joining us here
for this awesome match but i can guarantee you a
good amount of those people are laughing right now
anyway they're laughing at you not with you my
friend but that's they're still laughing i mean
bottom line is i made people laugh whether it's
at me or with me that's less important you made
me cringe um can you talk about the chess yes so
we have a slightly different structure and here we
have the position heating up d5 by duda basically
what why did he do that he did not want to allow
wesley to drive that wedge into the position by
playing d5 himself now there's a problem wesley
takes on f3 dude is going to take on c6 and who
does this favor how do we think about this well
remember dude is the one with the two bishops
and wesley is the one with the weak king
so queen takes f3 he dude has got the e file the
c6 pawn is weak unless wesley comes up with some
magical way to coordinate his pieces and fast he's
gonna be in trouble here maybe queen d7 coordinate
the rooks try to put a rook on e8 queen d7 by the
way threatens bishop g4 which would trap the queen
um but still bishop a4 now i think is very
unpleasant oh nice so he plays this first to
get rookie seven check bishop g4 traps the queen
but rookie 7 is check winning black's queens it
plays rookie now bishop a4 your idea makes
sense is there something knight d5 wait uh
okay can i trade take on d5 no it doesn't
work so i'll just bring up the analysis board
so that we're not doing that thing where we're
just talking in our heads bishop a4 puts pressure
on c6 knight d5 says no can do i'm blocking your
queen and i was wondering if i could sack my queen
to get your queen back but unfortunately at the
rookie seven check i'm just trading everything
off i have to take first and then rook f7 saves
the day so it's uh protecting the seventh rank
opposite colored bishops should just be in
equal game so we didn't get that with queen
d1 and the action continues opposite colored
bishops and the opposite excuse me two bishops
for white knight and bishop for black pawns
on both sides of the board so in theory donya
at the very least that should favor dude his
chances yeah uh definitely he is the one pushing
for the advantage but uh it should also be
pointed out that wesley is he's pretty active
uh and due to going after the queen trade which
again as you pointed out makes perfect sense that
pawn structure on on the queen side is incredibly
concerning in the long run for wesley i don't
think it's uh indefensible i think even if he
trades queens it should be a draw with best play
but that's a pretty big asterisk because it's
you know it's hard to find all those subtleties
and in energy maybe you take and you go bishop
to d3 nope he keeps the queens on the board
but now h4 ideas come into mind and uh
kingside attack is also not out of the question
right and that's an added benefit of keeping
the queens on is you can attack an exposed king
but i understand wesley's reluctance to trade
the queens off when you think about things in
how we're taught right bishop pair better than
knight and bishop when they're pawns on both
sides of the board double pawns not very promising
so the elements of the nuances of the position
certainly favor white from a high level thought
process so why should i trade queens and then
remove any chance i may have of sort of fending
off some of the bigger threats but i still like
jkd's position that's for sure and bishop b1
very interesting he's going after that a pawn
he was he wanted to play c4 and maybe he still
does and then redeploy that bishop to c3 that is
you know that's park place that's the central
park apartments oh wait i referenced new york
west coast festival's just for the record but
uh when's once that bishop gets there it's going
to exert tremendous pressure on the knight
and here we see it that pawn on a4 is also
a very very big weakness so a double whammy here
for wesley who is going to have to find some way
to keep his position together and we have a rare
occurrence wesley is down on the clock against jkd
and a big problem in addition to the a4 pawn being
a weakness how about this a2 pawn being an outside
pass pawn what am i thinking eventually play a3
to make sure i keep that pawn cemented in place
then play b3 spring free the outside pass pawn now
d5 says hey i'm going to try to get some play for
myself because my position is not looking good if
that bishop got to c3 but now what have you done
isolated doubled pawns isolated a
pawn queen in the center not a fan
uh pawn structure is not not fun now you don't
want to rush with bishop takes a4 that would
allow a queen trade at the end of the line i think
judah needs to find some way to tighten the screw
oh he does play a should pay for but i don't
know about that did he calculate queen d4 check
queen d4 i guess he said the outside pass pawn
should be good and donna i'm with you like trading
queens seems to give black decent chances to hold
the game but what he's probably thinking about and
he's going through the motions quite quickly here
is i have an a pawn and i also have an extra pawn
on the king side we have this three on two so
white is up a pawn we have the opposite color
bishop dynamic but i am going to keep your bishop
keeping after the a pawn and your king staying on
the king side after one of these three pawns and
that makes black slide very difficult as white's
king will then go try to run over into the queen
side so i'm ultimately with you that i think this
clearly increases black's chances to hold but
at the same time i believe that white has really
significant winning chances without a doubt
and uh it's it's good that you pointed that out
because a lot of people look at this and they wave
their hand and ah opposite colored bishops draw
uh but and oftentimes that is indeed the
case but i think in recent years uh with
these modern computers with the rise of magnus
we've begun to realize that the drawing margins
if you will in many positions are a lot narrower
than we initially thought and you pointed out the
two pass bonds as they say in russian trousers
you have that apon number one and you basically
have a past f pawn at any moment on demand you
can play g3 and f4 and create a second passer
and the ultimate concept here is to overextend
black's defensive resources black is gonna have
to assign the bishop the apon and the king
the f1 but that's a very uh risky situation
white could employ his king as well not gonna
be easy to win bishop d3 is coming here i think
but don't you like danya that the bishop cut off
the pawns from each other because black would have
loved to establish connected pawns and the bishop
won't be forced and not so fast that's a great
idea and and you've got to prevent that but black
does have the idea of inching his king toward d5
another thing to factor into the calculus
here white could go even g4 at some point
in order to fix the h and g pawns on dark squares
and then try to pick them off with bishop f8
we'll see what he chooses maybe king f2 for
now uh just to see where what black does
oh there we go nice so dania i think that he's
making uh both these uh come true right the pawns
on the queen side are sorry in the center of the
board are split you can't get c5 and to protect so
this pawn will either have to go to d3 in which
case you free up the other pieces and can i so
it takes king g7 is to say da wants to go to
h6 very good there's a problem with this very
concrete problem gh5 oh bishop c5 our same
idea bishop c5 bishop three are basically
catch and he plays bishop city and go look
at look at us and the problem is that king h6
h4 cool idea h4 and then you take the
pun and that is not just trousers that's
winning strategy very simple the bishop holds
together look at the bishop multitasking
that's the one thing knights can't do the
bishop multitasking defending g5 protecting d2
the king saunters its way to the queen side
and says bishop on a6 enjoy your stay at uh
the marriott uh a6 city because your residence
is about to end once the bishop once the king
lands on b6 just don't take this pawn because the
king for white is cut off so if this bishop were
to move d2 happens and you can't stop it so that's
the one he's going to do that for sure absolutely
that's it that's a little that's a tricky move
though these players they find tricks until the
last drop of blood has spilled robert they have
no resources and yet they're finding ways to
to uh you know to go for tricks but duda of
course a professional and what presence of mind by
a jkd to to recognize intuitively that the send
game is is winning and now that i saw this played
out i think it it was winning i've seen enough
opposite color bishop type positions in the pro
and it's a win for jkd he goes up two games
once more but enough opposite color bishop
type of positions in the pro-chess league and
various commenting events to be on the lookout
for hey wait a second there typically are ideas
that provide winning chances and dania i grew
up probably similar to you like we learned that
opposite-colored bishops shh it should be a draw
like most the time they're draw but i've fought
really hard against that initial thought to say
no let's look for the winning chances and there
goes duda right and um again the contributions
of magnus here have to be indicated uh he's sort
of said stuff like i don't believe in fortresses
uh and and we take that with with a grain of salt
but there's definitely a grain of truth to that
uh in the sense that you know the resources are so
abundant and we realize that now in in positions
where previously we would have dismissed
them i think as as drawn or as devoid of
of resources and we see another night off this one
a little bit more peaceful and as we've already
pointed out this time duda deploys his knight
to the traditional d7 square whereas in game one
uh he put it on c6 right he played a much
more active plan knight c6 knight a5 here
now it's wesley's pawn on a5 bishop on e3 trying
to take over the b6 square that's why the knight
on d7 is so important and it also is important
because if this knight we're on c6 i'll just
show you this very quickly let's say knight
d5 knight takes d5 pawn takes d5 for instance
there's no knight on c6 getting under attacking
with a fork so the 97 is much better placed
right and h6 again we see a little bit of
posturing here both sides improving their position
uh the idea of h6 obviously uh remove back
rank problems but also create the g5 square
that might seem insignificant but there are
some positions when a bishop lands on g5
and so wesley drops his bishop back
to f2 interesting interesting move
and that donna maybe i'm getting aggressive all
of a sudden because i'm looking at the score
seeing wesley's play are there ideas in the future
for g4 or is that just asking for way too much um
no i think there are and actually that's that's
one thing you can do is is lolly your opponent
to sleep but knight h5 preempting that going for
the f4 square so he's fulfilling the same idea
as in the beginning knight a5 knight c4 but on the
other side of the board this time not h5 knight f4
wesley's saying no you're
not you're not going nowhere
right and bishop g5 could have been an option
but if not for the d6 pawn right i was using
the bishop move to try to show everybody that this
d6 pawn is a huge problem for black but i guess
wesley figured the c2 pawn is a problem for
him and he wants to free up his knight but yep
i don't like the way this is going for wesley
now d5 is on the radar i have three defenders
of that square you uh don't have enough attackers
and why is this what rooksy one rook right back
to d1 i guess we have to give him a shout out for
when you recognize your mistake and there are no
huge consequences just say don't be so proud
as to avoid repeating your peace placement
sometimes it's better to say recognize it admit
it and then fix it definitely and uh we see duda
he's a night or specialist as i as i mentioned uh
previously but we'll see what he does now i mean
if you could get d five in that would be very good
by the way he did something similar with knight h5
knight f6 that was certainly not an admission
of failure remember he provoked g3 g3 is a very
significant and essentially a permanent weakness
of the king side and that's emphasized with that
h7 he's going after g5 and h3 potentially
wesley can play h4 to stop him but that's yet
another weakness he does maybe knight back to f6
i know that sounds crazy but you've done your job
it's it's funny done because i was half joking
about this g4 push earlier understanding how big
the squares would be and now look what's happening
if the knight goes to f6 will we see a g4 push i
i had f6 but the other knight that knight on h7
is there to sort of supervise the defense uh and
maybe duda is preparing d5 maybe he goes rook
d8 wesley trying to preempt him he's trying to
put a knight on d5 that's why he plays rook
c1 so that the c2 punt is not going to hang
so can you explain to me oh actually now i think
i get it so the queen was on c7 earlier and if he
had played ac1 that could have been bishop takes
b3 and queen takes a5 so with the queen on c6 and
the a5 pawn no longer be under under attack he
felt now was the time to bring the a rook over
because the rook did not need to sit and protect
a5 i was i was about to ask you why did he play
rook d to c1 earlier if he's only going to
play rook ac one later but it makes a lot
of sense now that i'm reflecting that's a great
explanation and now maybe queen drops back to e1
i don't know duda is he trying to go after t5 here
uh or is he trying to do something on the king
side you know you mentioned g4 robert i'm gonna
take a page out of your book and i'm going to say
dude i might want to play g5 and maybe he's
holding that knight on h7 uh he's saving it
for a rainy day maybe that rainy day has arrived
uh and he tries to turn it back on white bishop
takes d5 and g5 i know that sounds crazy but guess
what white's king side is so weak in that maybe he
can get away with it you don't have to encourage
me i'm happy to see g5 and played and the bishop's
already in so why not g5 next and then why
not f5 let's just push all these g5 let's go
i think he's going to do it because it's not
that he has infinite time wesley is saying
i'm not sleeping i'm going to go c5 and i'm going
to break open black's central defenses his rooks
are well positioned to do that dude has got one
moment and you're probably right about that c5 is
happening very shortly and one thing i'll keep
in the back of our mind is queen a4 timely queen
a4 could be a big nuisance to white but for now i
don't think it does what much attacks tonight i'll
defend my knight good for you so g5 is what i'm
looking at oh in no small part because you made
me and he's going for e4 is that four okay that
makes yeah definitely and that makes sense as well
i did like g5 i'm not entirely sure why but there
was something he didn't like about that duda knows
the night or fan the game of chess a lot better
than i do so i trust his decision making here
entirely strikes in the center with e4 as you said
robert and he's carving out all of these squares
for all of his pieces this is heating up
but i think black is having all the fun
i agree and magnus carlsen has shown great
skill in pretty much every position but in
particular in these kind of sicilians when he
pushes e4 sometimes even at the cost of a pawn
for example this knight we're on d7 you play e4
and if it's captured you bring the knight to e5
you're trying to loosen up white's control over
the light squares and then go forward and that's
a big problem for wesley right now as duda is
about even on the clock as wesley sits and thinks
about the ramifications of this decision so dania
it's looking better and better for jkd as his
pieces are coming to life yeah that's the that's
the night or for you once once these pieces unfurl
uh there's there's going to be a very big price
depend wesley regretting the pawn on g3 the pawn
on h4 these permanent and long-term weaknesses are
in in a very big way fueling the fire as he tries
to bring you know life-saving resources to the
game rook to c4 he's trying to get this e4 pawn
out of there on his own terms bringing the bishop
from e2 to f3 uh so that it lends support to these
incredibly weak squares on e4 and g4 will do to
preserve the tension play something like queen
f5 uh will he add more heat to the to the fire
baby bishop f8 uh essentially involving that rook
on e8 in the attack there's a lot of options
here he also doesn't have a lot of time what
does he do and this rook c4 not only does it put
pressure e4 and help out the king side eventually
i was gonna say there could be a b4 type of minion
what what is going on here oh e3 watch i was ready
i was about to say it i'm so happy you said that
because my first instinct because i was thinking
about e3 even before uh dtake c5 i was like can
i give up the pawn open up the e file and now the
point is that your bishop takes e3 let's bring up
the analysis board here is that there is a hanging
bishop on the square so bishop e3 i can even play
queen takes c6 exactly right bishop takes and your
bishop is hanging just like mine is we're on the
same page partner yes indeed i was really happy
you said that because i was thinking about it you
said it we're doing well donya come on man look at
that that's that's supportive teamwork that is for
i mean i i'm choking up here you know who else is
on the same page jkd well he's also leading on the
clock in addition to the scoreboard in addition
to the position so he decides to take with a
bishop you could say he's having a good day he
is having i mean you can just sense the good form
confidence and you know what's a great indicator
of good form the speed with which we went into
that opposite color bishop end game confidence to
to make critical and responsible decisions is an
underestimated metric of good form no hesitation
and accuracy and tactics this is not looking good
for wesley judah has decided to take with a bishop
on e6 preserving the queens uh which makes sense
because the queen on d7 is very well protected
can he take on c5 wesley hanging by a thread here
right bishop takes c5 you can't trade queens first
because there's an intermezzo bishop takes e3 with
check so after bishop takes c5 the bishop would
recapture it seems but keeping the queens on
the board should be good for black as white's
king is a bit looser at the pawns on f3 g3 and
h4 putting the king in an airy spot bishop g3
here is interesting by the way yeah okay so bishop
takes g3 the points if knight takes there's queen
takes here knight takes e4 first is probably
there's a whole smorgasbord of options here and
now this is collapsing for wesley's yeah simply
knight e4 queen e4 oh the best choice but queen
oh you look at you queen e3 king h2
though it's not over that look at that
king that might have been a little hasty
where is the queen f2 rookie two though
i mean f2 rookie two but there's a c8 yeah quincy
a queen f5 is that oh there's some beautiful
tactics there you queen f5 g6 bring up the now
bring up the analysis board real quick that way we
can show it's a queen f2 here rookie two if check
king h7 and if queen f5 you're saying g6 but i can
take and my king gets this square to run away to
no but you go 98 after queen uh c8 i think nope
he's he hasn't done it we'd have to take a look
we're going to tell us all we'll look now upon
down but look at wesley activating his rook
unbelievable come back robert he might even
be not worse here and g5 play but that gives the
f5 square that could be critical as if a knight
could land an outpost and the king could gain
some trouble credible stuff he's showing why won
the u.s championship this man is not sleeping
judo may be in great form but wesley so is a
monster and now he's overtaken the initiative four
seconds for doing it he might go g4 now wesley
met that square and n97 also learns knight
e5 as well very good call so one of those two
g4 oh that would have threatened some stuff too
okay well now this looks like it is probably going
to peter watch out don't 1194 tactics gg4 maybe
i actually don't like this at all for black it's
looking pretty bad and 1.9 seconds by the way
yep how how does oh okay the time is going on
how could you point seven seconds
it was going up the momentum
and great defense with no timer's
clock knight back knight c3
oh knight d2 he's he looks like d4 look at this
king of two he's getting out he's getting right
but rook d3 attacking that no he goes there
okay rookies think he's got to move it's like
so i'm gonna it's so close black is holding on
for dear life it is but look at judah this is
their their knight to d3 is going to come
at night he's going to establish his knife
attack f4 and there's 19 g5 ideas the
knight goes that f4 so be careful about that
knight of four knights he's just putting the
hot potato around and white continues to try
to find chances but look at duda knight t5
he's not missing any forks oh that's bad
that's that knight c3 93 that's it king
e6 but is the pawn ending winning f4
beautiful game over f5 and these are the margins
with which you have to beat these guys are we
sure it's over the king has to go to b3 this is a
very famous idea overextending the opposition king
could not have gone to b5 and now it's winning
because king is credible and the black king
you know has to make a choice at some point and
it's running out of options and yep kingston d6
you have made inroads six now you can king f5
you're gonna pick off the other pawn or king e6
oh my gosh what a win what a win by wesley we are
obviously bringing up the analysis board for that
game because that was a crazy finish indeed and
judah was doing his best to defend right it was
not an easy position but wesley he put all the
pressure on him and this was the moment here
allowing rook c5 was devastating for duda he needs
to keep his defense alive but once this knight
gets pinned it's forcing all the material off and
after rook c5 you can't move the knight knight c3
by the way just a tid but there was a very
beautiful win i think instead of knight c3
even knight takes g5 robert f4 not that this was
necessary but just pointing it out you're an evil
man but the real question is was there checkmate
earlier in the game we don't have to look at that
now uh but duda is definitely going to be thinking
about this as the next game gets underway it's so
hard robert to put these games out of your mind
we see duda here on camera he isn't too happy no
he's thinking about it he's lifting his
head up he's trying to remember the position
he's got to put it behind him and uh i think he
he will be able to and danya as we know very well
from playing you know over the board tournaments
even when you have one round a day sometimes you
get a position you're like wait this reminds me
of hess naraditsky from 2016 right we remember
our games and so we're like wait should i do this
or that when you're playing games back to back to
back to back you don't have time to get those
thoughts out of your head you're like wait that
game i just played did i miss checkmate i mean
his king was on h3 was there something there and
you're distracting yourself from the game at hand
and that makes you honestly play worse chess most
of the time and chess players are obsessive like
that it might from us from the side and by the way
knight five is is interesting but uh from the side
it might see well you know what's so difficult
about just not thinking about it but this is what
these players do this is what their passion is
this is their obsession and that is what it takes
and it's not as easy as turning an on and off
switch yeah and bishop b5 here might try to switch
off that e5 pawn but e4 and queen takes g3 has
to be watched for that knight on g3 is actually
vulnerable and it's in the crosshairs of the queen
that's a really instructive tactic that donna's
pointing out the bishop on b6 staring not just
at the f2 pawn but pinning the pawn so it's not
just about the attack also about the king being
behind it knight f1 the retreating move i'm still
looking at e4 ideas and he plays rookie at first
yeah he's cooking it up b4 might be very very
strong white's position is rattling on its
foundations and due to trying to go after
that e5 pawn it's really the only point of
contact that he has with black's position it's
the only vulnerability in wesley's position but
there's already sacrifices galore here e4
yep you called it robert i think he's gonna
crunch through white's position if he gets e4
in queensland maybe to stop it i don't know
like does it really stop it that's the essential
question that i think you and i both were like
not so sure so he i think that's actually very
smart white it is has this pawn e5 that you
wanted to target earlier now it's well defended
so let's trade off some pieces because you know
we're getting some trouble you can't take with
the bishop on e3 that's a really important point
because c3 hangs if you take with the f pawn
how do you like the pawns in the third rank
i love them they're the best
pawn structure i've ever seen
tell us how you really feel another awesome time
especially after black plays e4 and checkmates
yeah fe3 but can he well you know what
dude is thinking about bishop takes c3
saying all right i'm going to give up the
c3 pawn and i'm going to go bishop c4 check
but nah that's too much and he's better let's
do this bishop h3 is in the air queen g3
this looks terrible yeah this looks horrible
yeah you probably had to give up the pawn there
you did i think and he was correct think about
it but i think he should have taken the plunge
this looks almost lost is there a single move like
knight d4 this bishop takes h3 as you mentioned
h5 there may be yeah but you're just losing a pawn
and then hoping for compensation right yeah he's
trying to use his knight for defensive purposes
but can you still do it and bring a rook to f2
for example and just bring all your pieces in the
attack actually bishop takes h3gh immediately rook
f2 sacking the rook but that's made if he takes
it oh let's show that let us show that that's
actually that's gonna do it you are just an evil
man even now sorry go ahead well i'm just going to
show rook f2 it's king takes there's queen h2 and
the rook comes to fa it's mate but you're saying
rook f2 even now if you're bishop now bishop
takes d5 move the king away no too much but that
was interesting let me tell you i didn't see her
i didn't see a direct reputation to it i don't see
it either if i'm being honest with you but i see
that it's plus five i know folks i know i'm just
just putting it there probably just take it yeah
no need for that because gh again he has rook f2
it's it's not clear the eval bar went down after
all these moves so clearly black has compensation
in those lines but he said donya robert these are
my pieces i'm just going to recap exactly and i
you got to put the brakes on sometimes say i'm up
a pawn i'm attacking i'm going to go queen g6 here
i'm going to move the bishop away even to c8 so
that it potentially has access to the a6 square
and uh you don't want to rest on your laurels
here if you're black if duda consolidates
you know and by the year 2030 that a5 pawn i'm
keeping i'm taking a page out of grand master
hesis book i'm keeping an eye on it you get into
an end game nonchalantly white goes c4 guess what
pawn on a5 might might be a pretty hefty
price to pay so it's not like wesley is
playing without risk at all he's got to be
precise but that's what he's going to do i think
bishop takes g2 is is interesting continuing
the trend of giving up pieces but no bishop
sometimes it's best just to say i got what
i came for yeah now let me not get ahead of
myself so this move natural retreating
move by the way we have three minutes
remaining in this time patrol so unless the
game is decisive in the very near future this
will be our last game in the longest time patrol
yeah and um queen g3 here is incredibly juicy
but the problem is it doesn't really threaten
anything that knight on h2 i wouldn't dismiss it
it's actually a very strong defensive piece
because it's covering the g4 square and that
is prime real estate for the for the black bishop
and it can't get there so wesley instead deciding
to centralize his queen maybe c4 he wants to
meet with knight c3 getting rid of the bishop
duda doesn't allow it yeah and the queen was
in the same line as a rook you always have to
be on the lookout for that and black has what
seems to me to be perfect coordination to pieces
everything is doing an important job now maybe
let's bring this rook up to f6 and over to g6 he
says i'm bringing my knight back first and is he
going to h5 is she's trying to bring him up maybe
to g4 actually okay smoke out that knight on h2
which is the annoying piece and we just wanted to
take a a second to thank of course chessbra grand
masters hanson and hamilton the ogs for their
very big raid over 500 people joining us here
the speed chess championship match between
uh wesley so and jan just up dude are you
joining a good time uh we are moving toward
the tail end the last portion of the five
minute segment we have so much action left
yes indeed appreciate that to the bras good to
see you and well i'm not sure if jkd is so happy
to see them at this particular moment because
he would have preferred they rated when he was
winning the games not in this situation where hey
this king is in trouble white is uh upon down but
i just saw the evil go up to minus six and then
back down to minus two point seven five i don't
understand why he didn't go in he four immediately
uh that move looks completely devastating because
if white does not take the knight well if he
does he gets pinned and everything is lost
and if he doesn't then rook f2 comes i think
wesley's trying to finagle it and find the best
moment in time to play knight g4 but i don't know
if there's a need to finesse this should he try
bishop a5 just to attack something and actually
if i can get my bishop to this diagonal it would
be a good defender but your knight g4 is coming
no matter what still yeah but still i mean okay
i agree but still okay i just don't know what else
to bishop e1 maybe just to defend the f2 square
it seems like it said everything's yeah i don't
see a move maybe you don't move the bishop at all
but no that would that would that's a great idea
yes let's give up the bishop and allow an iq four
yeah this look at the time minus
four nine g4 looks really strong but
then rook f1 i think he's found the best of the
worst because then um okay bishop ah that's nasty
this is over alright for checkmate wesley
h5 who's strong downstairs and there's five
seconds left so this game is resigned right
now they would have a uh one more game nope
so clinical by wesley bishop g4 he just finds the
most surgical way of winning queen h4 here is just
well then g3 due to trying to give up a couple
pawns and again let's not forget about that past
a pawn wesley can't just get into an end game
willy nilly that's why knight e5 comes to mind
trying to swing that knight around to f3
that seems like an interesting idea as well
oh you're you're just a mean mean man he does
this a brace queen back to each age four yep
and then 95. your your point is very well taken
about this outside past pawn because if you trade
queens that could end up being a bit of a problem
for you even though black is still doing very well
he keeps the queens on the board and
trying to trade at all costs yeah rook d8 rook f4
all right some intrigue left pinning and hitting
e4 and there's a pawn we keep talking about it if
you trade pieces then i have an outside past pawn
that you're going to struggle to deal with yeah
definitely and great thing again wesley's time
management has been superb and he's left himself
quite a bit of time to to think through these
critical moments but uh yeah he's got definitely
some pretty rook v8 to stop the rook from moving
away from the the first string so that because of
rook b1 i think maybe rogue b8 is the key but then
maybe bishop c3 ah e3 pinning the knight because
you're threatening uh the g7 pawn i could buy that
yeah and what's happening here with the watch last
taking his time he is up plenty of it and he
traces the last game officially of the five
minute portion and he decides to go after white
spawns that makes sense yeah but a5 is coming
yeah no i agree queen okay that's a nice
move because if g6 queen h4 that queen is
trying to snake in here and you can tell that
wesley's not very happy he's no he's let i mean
this should never have it should never have come
this close but 95 now finally the knight gets to
and that is crunch knight d3 queen of he's
gonna go after white's king here yes hanging
for good measure everything's a problem so
high five due to trying everything he can
i would play queen e2 and then a6 knight
takes d2 and the a6 pawn hangs at the end
knight takes a five minute five just get rid
of that bomb there must be someone like queen
g5 or something he was worried about wait i
didn't like that their fall queen d3 check
careful now lost oh i thought he lost in time
it was so close we lost on time this is not
clear no it wasn't clear at all d7 queen c7 oh
my god back in the game he lost back in the game
because he outside past pawn oh my lance i know
this is crazy but these positions can be lost
but in a perpetual attempt there with queen f4
as well wow wow and okay to be fair to wesleyan
young kristoff wesley was dominating at home games
even if jkd had some chances toward the end wesley
was still better and it would have been a tough
sledding for duda however the score is now four to
four donna any final thoughts before we head into
our break incredible action both players having
their highlights and their low lights we expected
a close match we are getting one uh judah showing
amazing form early but some missed opportunities
for both players they're gonna have to think about
their strategy think about their opening and they
have a little break to do that i can't wait robert
for the three minute portion we're going to see
these players reinvigorate and we're going to see
another 60 minutes of incredible action well
we are going to take a break we'll be back in
a few minutes but for those of you who are
subscribed to the channel you will enjoy a prime
time smackdown of the one and only gotham chest
taking on the hammer we'll be right back everybody
i have a little public service announcement
i've been playing this uh opening in uh one
minute chess since i was 12 years old and
it's horrible do not play it like this
but it's good enough to beat levi though you
god that is just so evil that it that like
i i didn't even have a chance to concentrate
this man just i was like ready to start okay
this opening it's so bad yet it's so
good i i don't know how to explain it
i still have not fully adapted to this format
normally i am just talking into my own camp
okay i'm just talking into my own camera and
talking trash against people who can't hear me
and in this particular case i have somebody
who can hear me and it's unnerving i don't
think i played that very well i'm winning on
time i'm winning on position i'm winning on
pretty much every everything you can be winning
in yeah this format is a bit strange i already
feel like i'm making inaccurate moves uh-huh
because i have to talk and fill the air time
or else they're not going to pay me for showing
up and it's like it's just yeah it's it's it
it's weird like i want to just sit here and and
try to win and not just be a content farm but
i think i'm just gonna end up being a content
farm that's okay and then it's like i don't
want to talk on my opponent's move because i feel
like that's a little disrespectful maybe i'm just
gonna do that it's the only way i can beat
hammer i think definitely will be doing that
i have no qualms about such such things okay
good start you you have no idea how many times
i have uh won a piece like that you're you're not
the first one to to drop a fork on the hot how
the fact that you know theory in
this is like even more terrifying
how how can i not know theory i played it like
you know are we still in theory 30 40 000 times
no i never played anything like this actually
my move knight h6 was a recent discovery i made
a very a big improvement on the
way i played this previously
do you have you trained this with magnus at all
no but i think he's warming up to this opening
because sometimes uh when he's streaming
he will go oh i'll test out the hammer
oh you know once upon a time when we were
kids i legitimately consider myself a better
uh one minute player than magnus i think that's
probably still true no he he got good i don't know
really yeah he almost lost to me once yeah
but he was dominating some some online
one-minute tournaments he wasn't able
to do that previously it's like so
slow oh my god yeah but this is this is my trick
this is my trick so i i will sin since you're
being generous and kind of just giving me check
made in one move i'll i'll share a secret with you
and do not forget to get involved with guest
the move you see some of the top guessers here
international master venia03 with a great score
and if that were the game that was selected we
don't know what it will be i believe it's
chosen random that would be a cool 75 bucks
in your pocket so please do get involved on
chess.com live while you follow the games and
speaking of cool things on chess.com not
cash related but beth harmon is pretty
cash when it comes to chess now donya i have
not finished the queen's gambit yet i'm only
episodes in still haven't watched more so i don't
know quite how good beth harmon gets and there
are seven different ages in addition to 70 other
adaptive or celebrity bots on chess.com available
but i don't know quite how good she gets so
don't ruin it for me but you should play it's
good uh but you know what i don't know is the
outcome of this current match that we're watching
i think beth harmon would have loved to see wesley
so and jan schistov due to duking it out of course
wesley the pre-match favored by a relatively slim
margin according to smarter chess predictions we
called a close match and we're getting one robert
all tied up after the five minute portion and of
course we have smarter chess in the chat saying
good start for duda and yeah it is good because
wesley so is predicted as a one game favorite
in the longest time patrol he was not able to
get that lead and so with that being the case and
as we see here well he has work cut out for him
because the quicker time controls will favor young
christian well i should say the quickest time to
show because this one a three game favorite for
wesley so what do you think about that danya
i don't know i and and i explained this
before the match i think that duda has
improved tremendously in uh faster time controls
and it's hard to factor in the trend right the
trend is something that's less tangible when you
look at the ratings you look at the results but
as far as i've seen from duda's bullet games he's
gotten faster he's gotten a little bit crisper
in the decision making not that he's ever been
bad i mean he's been a beast for for years and
he's he's awesome in every sense of the word uh
but i think that that might play a role now wesley
again that boa constrictor style uh can serve him
very well he really knows how to shut people down
and we'll see which of those styles and tendencies
reigns supreme for sure and wesley is so strong
at the three-minute segment in these sec matches
that he actually defeated magnus in that in their
uh match and yeah only that i mean not a big
deal that really indicate anything though i mean
who hasn't defeated that man just in everyday
occurrence these days just super exciting but
uh in all seriousness wesley obviously an absolute
force and we are switching from a sicilian which
we've seen been played when jkd is black to
now d4 on the first one for wesley so what
do you make of that opening change by wesley
interesting interesting stuff i mean i think
during the breaks i was going to say you know i
wonder what the players do i think some players
just go take a breather you know drink their
espresso but some players they look at the games
uh it's like you imagine that boxing break you
know the coach tells them the motivational couple
of words here you just quickly decide all right
am i going to keep this opening when i keep that
opening maybe they look something up really
quickly and that really adds to the intrigue
because we really see the decision making
of these players in action uh which i always
feel like is awesome it's a window into these
players minds you can see the wheels turning
wesley very interesting and duda taking the first
long think uh i'm sure this is theory but this is
a very dangerous position if black doesn't know
what to do that knight on e4 could get trapped
after c5 f3 begin becomes threatened he plays
f3 immediately right so the knight does have
the d6 chord which is why you mentioned c5 and i
have played this from the white side before so i
know that the common idea is to play d5 for black
and i could have been mixing up my line so that
actually happens even at the game's very highest
levels with players of the caliber of wesley and
jkd is they know the different ideas but maybe a
subtle change in the move order or will say well
the idea with d5 in the other variation will not
work out here so that's why jkd is just ensuring
that he remembered the right line but now bishop
d7 there could be a problem with the knight on
f5 hanging important tactic right oh that's
very interesting and look at the time and dude
when you whenever you have to move the king
to heaven that is a very bad sign this is
opening domination robert unless i'm
getting the wrong read on the position
this looks absolutely horrendous but for jkd well
you're a voracious reader i see all those books on
your shelves you're absolutely correct here uh the
one issue that wesley will have to solve is his
problem on e3 you would love to put your bishop on
b2 and just aim at the e5 pawn but then you lose
the defense of the e3 square so a5 plate i think
that's a very good choice by young christophe duda
here to open up the queen side as his king is
on f8 which makes his rook on h8 pretty useless
for the time b right and uh wesley just shifting
his rook to be when you're saying you know what
yon take that eight file i don't care about
the a file take it to your heart's content
it resolves the tension now you mentioned the
e3 pawn wesley can resolve that gradually he can
castle go rook d1 eventually he can try to push
that pawn to e4 the problem for duda is just i
don't see how you stop wesley from doing that if
white consolidates and completes his development
and here we see it due to trying to do something
to you know to change the trend of the game but e4
and there we have it he doesn't care about the
past pawn the bishop on b5 doing a great job
protecting the d3 square and knight h4 is trying
to be a nuisance but after you castle where's
the attack coming from four is interesting f4
right saying hey you're not going to attack me
i'm going to attack you your king's on f8 my
rook's on f1 and dania you called it here it
goes yeah knight g6 might be a sad necessity here
trying to hold things together yeah he does it but
man fe and knight f4 even just very natural
play look at the time disparity as well terrible
terrible position for jkd wouldn't discount him
these people are monsters at defending and what a
move h3 h3 i don't know if this is a good move
but it's a move i would not play i was thinking
of bishop to b2 to hit at the d4 pawn another
time and then eventually take on e5 but wesley
just goes i don't want your knight coming to
g4 i don't want your bishop coming to g4 let
me take away that square from your pieces i know
but should be two yeah i really like that move
i was thinking about something more
concrete but the more i look at this yeah
you don't want to take on e5 prematurely
because that gives up some squares
so bishop b2 okay bishop c4 stopping king h7 look
at wesley just again the boa constrictor mentality
let me stop all the threats first but bishop b6
here maybe he's an interesting defensive attempt
and he goes for i think you could take it by queen
b3 is what i'm imagining or queen c4 might even be
stronger but after uh bishop e6 if you take back
queen into the city maybe king h7 and at least
i evacuate my king i go rookie eight you know i'm
not sure i think wesley might have played a little
bit too slowly here you have a good point that
with the king going h7 even if it costs you a pawn
yep don't forget about this open a file we like
the a5 earlier and if we start trading off pieces
that rook can infiltrate and i'm with you diana
the pawn e4 isn't exactly so stable it's uh not
protected by another pawn i think that jkd's
chances have improved greatly but his time
he's down at 21 seconds wesley taking a long
thing that is perhaps the most indicative of
of the fact that he recognizes something has
gone astray this move bishop c4 i liked h3
bishop c4 took it a notch too
far i think he should have went
he should have gone on the offensive now bishop
d3 i like this too he's preserving the tension
uh based on black stock but f5 now oh just
a winning of peace wow rook b2 i think duda
yeah not sure just too low on time it's impossible
to defend this and good job by wesley hunkering
down finding the move and now he's a peace out
do you think dude is just playing it out to get
closer and closer to that one-minute time control
yeah i think so maybe he's entertaining some
hopes king h7 at least he's made his king safe
it's going to cost a small price of a piece but
because if this were a classical game he of
course would resign oh totally and knight and
it's not just a piece i mean look at the dominate
bishop on d3 blockading the pawn white's pieces
are perfectly arranged he's going to resign here
i think he's going to no still bishop c1 queen f2
by the way interesting idea that's in wesley's
style we'll make sure to ask the players after
the match but this is a question that we will
probably continue asking ourselves in the audience
is young christoph duda trying to waste as
much time as possible to get to the bullet
where that is his biggest chance he's seeing
the smart chess predictions and he made sure
to exit the five minute portion even rather than
down a game which is the prediction he wants to
minimize the damage in the three-minute portion
no and these players they strategize you know
they think before the match right oh bishop bishop
h6 that had some tapatio sauce on top of that and
uh wesley jumping out a point
ahead but to complete my thought
it you know these players they strategize they
think about where they're the favorites you know
what they want uh it's not that they resolve to
lose a section right they they want to win every
segment but they're also realistic and uh this
isn't just yan getting tilted i think this is all
very measured and thought out and i agree what
i laugh because wesley was fixing his camera he
knows how to play to the crowd he was looking at
the position and then grabbed the camera so it had
a better angle so thank you wesley we appreciate
it looking up at the camera hello wesley all right
you're allowed to focus on the game now
give us a smile give us a wave you can
hear us no of course he cannot hear us
but uh about the game we have a position
where we had one pawn trader per side the c pawn
is gone for white giving the queen on c2 a longer
file the rook on e8 similarly has a semi-open file
to work with and white has not castled so what do
you make of this dynamic what are the ideas for
black are you going c5 in the future is that too
risky help us understand what's going on yeah i
mean i i don't know these positions too well i do
think black deploys this bishop to b7 which might
seem weird right because the bishop is biting
on granite but b6 as you pointed out has the uh
alternate intention of preparing c5 which jan uh
prevents with b4 so what's happening here is
i think the battle will revolve around whether
black can play c5 in the correct version what
wesley can do he can play bishop b7 rook c8 he
can still try to go c5 now yes at the end of the
day you'll have an isolated pawn on d5 but white's
pieces can get sort of tangled up the queen on
the c file the alternate plan oh c5 immediately
here we go here we go now he's going to try to
eliminate that bishop on d3 and get the two bishop
advantage so very interesting position i don't
know who's better duda doesn't have to take on
c5 but he can go bishop b2 right i kind of like
that wesley played c5 immediately without putting
the bishop on b7 because the bishop on b7 would
have been under attack when the rook comes to b1
now we can play c4 you can play g6 you called all
of this and there are pluses and minuses here the
good thing for black you have sort of protected
pass pawn on c4 the bad thing is that this pawn
d5 can be undermined or attacked at some point
but the biggest issue that judah is facing is
his bishop on c1 you want that bishop to be out
here on g5 yeah hit this knight f6 to get after
d5 the bishop's not going anywhere e4 maybe is
a crazy attempt to muddy muddy the waters but
honestly i do think this calls for desperate
robert i may be overstating this but if you take
the knight on d7 bishop takes dc i think judah
seriously contemplated movie four here because
he's got to do something about this but uh yeah
this is or some sort of other sacrifice knight d5
uh but this all just this can't
work wesley's disconnected
unless no you're right i see that one bar nope
he's back okay okay good i was like we see him
still showing the red bar in my end of this on
my computer but hopefully we'll he'll be fine
and do it it takes on d7 yep he's back whoa
g4 g4 in the world is that i'm taking this
whatever take me take with whatever okay bishop g4
uh hg knight g4 king g2 oh queen h4 resigns okay
oh my oh my gosh this looks so tough this is the
most tempting move in the history of chess like
knight g4 bishop g4 oh yeah knight g4 also not
that dumb of an idea i think because you preserve
the bishop on d7 it can go to f5 later i think
wesley's deciding not whether he will take on g4
but which piece he'll take it with right and then
he takes it oh bishop oh no that doesn't work okay
that queen h4 coming here it is bishop f5 at the
end like you were just saying yep okay so there
we go f5 is a threat knight d5 maybe oh bishop
f3 on top of everything else oh this is nasty
um i'm gonna be honest with you
donya this isn't the best game
from jkd ship f3 by the way yes we have three
queens between me oh lobster and look at
you know kristoff he's just like takes a swig of
water and he's like nope not to be outdone and
the water theorem comes into play i mentioned this
in a previous match robert when and i have to give
credit here to my good friend uh peter gionatus of
the charlotte chess center he coined this whenever
a player is like comfortable the way match is
going you immediately see whatever beverage
is nearby they're taking that sip of water
there's no there has never been well dude it
just violated the rule but usually when you've
got a bad position that water remains untouched
and what a win by wesley but yeah not the best
game for duda as i see smarter chess making
his way very proud of his prediction in the chat
saying wesley in three plus one and that's all you
need to say wesley is untouchable it feels like
in that time patrol even against magnus carlsen so
he's in trouble yeah it's just the right balance
that wesley's able to find right between intuition
and calculation he's got that style where he does
a little bit of both and both of those skills for
him are so well developed judah's gotta put the
brakes on this and and maybe just draw a game
with black uh hit a free throw stabilize and
then it's only two points but he doesn't want
to let the spiral out of control yeah you and your
sports references today i forgot about thompson i
just came back and i'm pretty devastated yeah um
you know season and can you believe this anyways
i actually can believe it i'm not happy about it
but it's terrible he's terrible terrible he's my
favorite player well behind steph curry but that
was nothing so in other words you lied he's not
your favorite player no they're they're they're
sharing first place basically and i'm guessing
james weissman is also your favorite player now
that the warriors okay we'll talk about this later
yeah talk about it the knight on e5 good piece
the pawn on d5 not so good pawn so these seven
positions isolated pawn we've talked about those
earlier where you want to blockade the pawn make
sure it can't push and trade off and go after it
later in the game so wesley has a calm approach
he's saying i can put my queen on d4 and just
say that pawn d5 stuck in his tracks yeah even d4
might be something to consider for due to sacking
we saw wesley do something remotely similar in
a previous game sacking the pawn to open some
arab i don't think the occasion calls for that
but i would consider a way to maybe go queen d6
something where you eventually want to absolve
yourself of this weakness the good thing about
queen d6 is also that black eyes the h2 square
he'd have some knight g4 ideas i'm not saying
there's any chance the black delivers mate here
dude is definitely worse here but i think he can
hold this together he goes queen f6 okay i want
to show something very quickly and i think it's
important and so we'll bring the analysis board
just to call attention to it your idea with queen
d6 and knight g4 is really nice and the one thing
i was going to say is that a really cool thing
for white is you could play with like queen c7
so just because mate is under attack doesn't
mean you need to block the attacking piece or
to defend it more directly the queen protects
h2 through the enemy queen offering the trade
taking over the c file hitting the queenside
pawn so i just want to show that little trick
very quickly i love the x-ray ideas you know i'm
just trying to be an accommodating co-commentator
so i'm here for you buddy yeah mostly you're
succeeding but we'll talk about that afterwards
we have some stuff to renegotiate well the state
of affairs in in denmark uh or in duda's position
are not great he's a minute down on the clock
again that narrative and well where's denmark come
from it's reference shakespeare reference right
okay got it you know i'm not really well versed on
my shakespeare at the moment but no i i've never i
trust me i've only read spark notes but what's the
isn't it rotten in the state of denmark i think
yeah we can we can talk about you know hamlet and
things a little bit later no i think we should
talk about now all right so let's just be clear
blockade the queen on d4 very happy you can
replace that with a knight knight f3 uh and
i'm getting to the end game where the knight is
very strong the bishop on e6 is stuck protecting
the d5 pawn so not a very good piece whereas
white's pieces have a free range oh here's the one
rook b8 might be a sad necessity it is now the
knight's gonna come to b3 or f3 most likely um
probably i kind of like b3 more because you have
more squares to go to even a5 but if bishop b5
not allowing the knight to go to e8 to kick the
rook i would seriously consider d4 and knight
t5 just saying all right i don't care i'm just
going to get some activity for my pieces and
i'm going to get that rook out of c7 i would
i would play d4 here if i were to yeah how
about maybe wesley goes e4 not even take it just
push through he plays a6 all right maybe d4 now
you can also why you know rook see you can you get
rook c8 in here try oh and rook b7 and he does it
and then d4 finally and then it happens tactically
and white's in big trouble exactly so rook c8 is
forced now white preserves in advance but that
is a huge win for black to trade brooks that this
should be a draw now right king comes to d6 but
white is still better because the pawn isolated
you need to defend it and we actually saw an end
game like this who was the match it was a dude
against fabiano where it was light square bishop
bad one versus good one and the bishop came to b3
and put pressure in the pawn and eventually e4 was
played i think that was the duda fobby match and
that as i'm thinking about it you don't want to
eliminate in our minds the chances that white has
here because he is certainly better yeah without a
doubt and and 26 seconds he's still a minute up on
the clock uh you don't want to fall asleep here if
you're white there's you know you can let things
out of control f5 is an interesting resource by
duda trying to trade some pawns get that king out
of d4 even h5 the more pawns he trades and he goes
g5 he fixes the pawn on g4 i think he's gonna play
one of these moves f5 at some point maybe knight
g6 also for now he brings his pieces into the game
an idea for wesley to play f4 potentially so
it's hard to generate chances here for white
robert i'm beginning to think this is just
a draw yeah f4 does invite f5 yeah exactly
you have to be careful if you push too far it can
backfire yeah and this knight would like to kick
the king out but i do not want to give up the
knight for a bishop that's a really important
point the bishop on e6 is quite useless and then
white would take over all the dark squares so
knight c6 check would be a very poor decision and
e4 i thought about that but f6 stopping e5 check
uh and maybe beef i know could black he's got
to be careful here i know that sounds crazy but
he really does i was asking the same thing like
can black be better the f4 scale is blacks for
the taking i yeah i know again okay he does go b5
i thought bishop d7 but then b takes a6 no bishop
a4 oh bishop d7 here is very nasty okay he doesn't
do it but i guess there's he takes d5 that's why
yeah you want to keep this point right as possible
but no you're coming up with clever shots there
and by the way due to down to 9.4 seconds he
is holding very well he should not be in any
big trouble but when you don't have time and maybe
one tricky situation arises he will not have at f4
though tricky situation or isn't on the other side
okay wesley trying to distract his attention maybe
move the bishop away to b7 or something c6 yeah
he was bishop c6 and that's what he's offering
a trade of bishops is knight f4 he goes for it
knight c4 93 the f3 is hanging so you have to
knight e4 check is interesting trying to inch the
king closer metaphor go so what no wesley is kind
of playing for a win but he's playing with fire
he can be worse 96 check 96 check and then king
comes in black's keeping saving all so that needs
to be factored in on h5 trying to give this pawn
to h4 wow splitting the pawn jason now he's got
weaknesses all over the place knight back to f4
bishop five that's what he wants to accomplish is
have a more active piece but look at this there's
a problem the other side of the board daniel oh
b5 push going on he takes it bishop f3 he's got it
he's got a chance now h4 wesley trying to remove
the pieces from the board he's gonna succeed he's
gonna move if he took the pawn was king e3 forking
the two pieces so black can never lose this game
but at all does he have any winning chances not
really yeah take it take this pawn wow that was
more interesting than it looked like if you look
at that game casually ah you know equal end game
okay they drew but there's a lot of tension
underwater there and due to in a certain sense
succeeding and drawing with black he's got to make
something of the white pieces and we were talking
about this donut white initially was better
because the isolated pawn but we saw wesley's
are pushing a little bit too much and wesley knew
it he was very conscientiously saying i'm going
to try to press for win because judo doesn't
have time i think he understood he was risking
his position as well but now dude with the white
pieces as you just said dania he needs to prove
an advantage here rather than allowing wesley to
have simple play where frankly he's the better of
the two players in the three minute yeah and uh we
have another nimso another variation of the nimzo
and uh this one i don't know too much about i
mean these bishops on b2 and a2 produce kind of
an amusing effect uh they're the kinds of pieces
that could be monsters they could be terrible
i as far as i remember uh wesley well probably
black goes like knight c6 and at some point e5
to stir things up in the center because
that bishop on a6 is definitely a beast
we know where that bishop is uh going
to be in the bishops hall of fame
c4 first ballot hall of famer there from right the
bishop on a6 not anymore though now the bishop's
closed off so this was this was in his prime it
was bound for the hall now it's like i mean you
play a couple more years too though i don't know
about that that's like carmilla anthony we knew
that was going to the hall of shame okay she said
what are you going after the trailblazers now they
just signed robert covington and you're going
after them they got dame dollar they they have
trust me i'm just i'm going after a very
specific player oh okay well i mean cj become
the basketball again yeah what's your fault so
i think it's your phone i don't think i'm gonna
comment to anything so e5 is the threat to queen
e2 is that yeah but then you pin yourself against
the queen on a6 so what you're essentially telling
me is you don't really like the isolated pawns on
the queen side for white and you prefer black's
structure yeah i don't know why but i feel like
i do so dude is thinking about where to put his
queen queen a4 is possible but every one of these
moves is a drawback na4 brings the queen away from
the king side and wesley's gonna play bishop b7
and then if white castle short he's going to
regret having the queen on a4 black's going
to go knight g4 all of a sudden that attack
is going to come so fast this is a very hard
decision robert i think dude is in trouble again
and again he's low on time yeah i was just showing
that very quickly come back to live position but
it's a very important point that if the queen gets
distracted all over the queen side your king is
not going to be happy about the consequences so
he plays queen 2 that's reasonable protecting
c4 another time even though you're walking
to a pin perhaps there's knight to b5 just to
attack the queen and make c4 feel a little bit
more defended and danya the bishop on
b2 it is now in the open so is that
enough for white or is the c4 pawn so weak
that oh look at that move oh cb queen 85
move that's right that is that's technique that
is skill right there playing it really is i love
it that is such a classy move and it puts dude in
such a difficult spot so the idea is c takes b5
it seems like a blunder right what are you
doing queen is saying bishop is saying but
quinn a5 chuck and if bishop c3 he can take on
b5 but he can also take on a3 attacking the rook
on c1 spoiled for choice and just very if we
play a little bit more simplistically now we
have an isolated pawn and black has control of
the square in front of it the blockading square
oh and not just control but domination over i
mean just total dominance over the d5 square
duda one should mention has a solid position
these positions are sometimes overestimated
because it's actually hard to make progress here
in the long run look at duda's bot on c5 pawn on
d4 well protected so work to be done for wesley a
lot of work indeed and we talked about the attack
that wesley tried to drum up in that game where
he had an isolated pawn rather than the backward
pawn but they have some similarities right you
blockade a backwards pawn and you put pressure
on it so this pawn d4 isn't the happiest
but white's bishop pair that will give him
chances here now g two under look at that
look at dude said please take a minute yeah
you might throw in a g5 absolutely if bishop
takes she's daring wesley to say country too
i don't think he's gonna do that because d5
rook g3 now you have two bishops staring at the
black king side and i know a ton of arrows but
it's worth it right and again the time is going
to factor in here duda be well below a minute now
i i mean as soon as this gets tactical that's the
issue it's not when the position remains
close it's when the position gets tactical
just not going to have the time to to process
everything queen c2 now he's got the battery going
against that he can complete the rook left wesley
will have some stuff to deal with on the king's
side if he does that when he does that potentially
i'm into it and do not take this pawn on d4 that
okay i thought for a second he did i saw the rook
what if i don't do it no no he put his work on d5
to actually help himself out and maybe try to land
an attack and rook g3 of course the bishop on b2
still defending this pawn and black
to his credit he's really stabilized
his position the bishop on c4 rook on d5 uh it's
not like white can make easy progress here so
how do you behave well maybe well first of
all the moment the rook moves away from d5
white's going gonna play d5 he's just
gonna like a shark coming out of the water
gasping for breath it's you know he's that rook on
d5 it's good but it's also uh holding the world on
its shoulders bishop d1 bishop f3 is a maneuver
that i think dude is considering here trying to
get that rook out of there well he doesn't have
too much time to consider things and you know
he's got 13 seconds and i do like white's position
but i trust wesley so as we say rook g4 knight f6
back and forth i think we're cap three i don't
see a downside to that i know he does go rook g4
i told you no no you're really you're looking
he's eight he's eight seconds danya rook f4
he's gotta decide something four seconds
wesley's not repeating moves is he yeah yes
see my camera may be doing funky things today
that make me seem extremely beat right i don't
know what's happening these draw by repetitions
sadly i've grown accustomed to them i want to see
action unfold every single time but that was
well played defense by wesley just making sure
he wasn't getting in trouble and he has a
two-game lead donya so right i don't think
he could have done much there yeah i wouldn't
dismiss that decision i actually think that the
more i looked at that position the moment you do
something a little bit inaccurate duda gets his
bishops active and it could turn from looking good
to getting checkmated in a moment and wesley again
he's up two points he believes in his skill he's
got half of the three-minute segment to go he's
got the white pieces he sees no purpose in taking
what he feels is unnecessary risk of force i also
i'm a big fan of action but that's that's the
decision he's he's made yes indeed and now we have
a pawn that can be captured on e5 or do you
capture the pawn on d5 first that's what
he's thinking about he's trying to figure
he takes on d5 and one of those examples
of a known position but you just want to make sure
that you're remembering it correctly because you
make one inaccuracy and all of a sudden white
gets the initiative and you're like okay why
didn't i take on d5 before taking on e5 so he
did do that the bishop one d5 looks good the
bishop on e5 also looks good will bishop
h6 be a thing will bishop h3 be a thing
it's essentially that whites up a tempo in the
entirely symmetrical position right and uh these
are actually very unpleasant uh you know it seems
it has this air of a symmetrical position but it
needs to be played with great accuracy by black uh
in order as you said to not allow this extra tempo
to spiral out of control into an initiative queen
me thinks i like he's kind of pre-empting queen b3
he's preparing rook d8 wesley though deploying
his bishop to h6 this this thing is heating up
it certainly is and rook d8 looks very natural
here the one downside of rook d8 is if the queen
is forced away from the defense there could
be a bishop takes f7 check right because rooks
tend to win the stare down on an open file when
there's a piece in between a rook and a queen but
you can get a discovery at some moment so instead
bishop g7 was played looks reasonable if this
queen needs to help the diagonal you can go to
f6 but importantly you're stopping the queen from
getting to d4 dania white is up more or less two
developing moves at the moment yeah but because
there's no there are no weaknesses right so that's
how relevant is that lead in development well
he's got to make something happen in the next
couple of moves because what is black going to do
he's well knight a4 that's what wesley's trying
because if duda gets his knight from b8 let's say
to f6 okay the problems have been solved as king
is safe so wesley is trying to get that d4 square
for his queen and judah might want to slide his
queen around to f6 to prevent that from happening
that however contains its own drawbacks wesley can
then imitate him and position his own queen on b3
attacking the b7 pawn so duda that knight a4 is an
amazing sorry to interrupt you because rook takes
c8 there as well right queen of six rook takes ceo
let's show the announcement oh no you didn't oh
yes i did my friend hey i'm just stealing a pawn
you know why not i'm just evil i'm a pawn grabber
but knight a4 robert that's the kind of move
you look at okay let's move on it's actually
a brilliant move it forces black to make a very
committal decision and queen before it you had
to stop that a3 is possible he's keeping b7
defend and keeping d4 neutral goes queen g4
rook c8 isn't it bike don't forget wait means
coming back queen c8 that's hilarious but
oh my there's a crazy line but anyways queen b3
i think is the safe continuation but there's so
many choices here white can make what else can he
do he can try to keep the queen away from g4 you
can play f3 although that's pretty weakening yeah
that doesn't come recommended no definitely not
e4 even but wesley definitely correct in taking
his time here he senses that this is a moment
he could really press while the iron is hot he
doesn't want to mess this up and rook takes d5
let's say black and move would look like a
threat because you take one piece when the
queen takes back you take a second piece but
the issue is your bishop on c8 loses defender
so i was thinking about ideas with a rook takes d5
the knight not defended any longer on a4 but you
can't get away with it with this bishop hanging
so he plays f3 who are you donya i don't know
that move looks so bad to me i agree but
he sees something very concrete i think he
really wants to get that queen of his to d4 at
all costs and he thinks that if he does that
his problems are going to be solved but actually
queen d4 check i was a little bit worried about e5
i was worried about e5 here because queen
takes e5 f6 oh and then queen c7 i see also
you're not actually attacking the bishop on d5
because that falls apart that's rook fd1 now
but that knight c6 and there's also e6 ideas you
need to keep an eye on for because uh the bishop's
pinned yeah so rook f2196 and knight c yeah i
don't know i think knight c6 is almost forced
okay it's knight c6 you're saying so e6 there
must be some tactical flow there must be
like one five maybe or queen takes d5 so
maybe not next queen a4 oh so it was 95.
i was like that was my intuition but but
now it's not loving it so is it queen guess
we're about to find out queen's except for
that's gonna happen is there some b5 there no
wait so wesley falling for the same trap that
i just fell for because i see the eval bar
oh i think it's queen e5 oh my
gosh just pick queen f7 that's it
instead of capturing instead of being greedy
he's from queen f7 and well that's a problem
this is this is a pretty serious problem
i'd say because that bishop cannot move
now wait a minute what is going on
here in the speed of the what what
robert rook d8 is this gonna sustain itself though
well for on a worst case scenario duda can play
rook a6 rook b6 give the knight back up uh and and
win b2 i think he's preparing for that yes because
this is a long journey he's just going kd6 and
then knight d7 if you take on g6 but the problem
is that's too many pawns and the pawns are fast
it plays b5 i think jgd sees the score he wants
to win but he's six seconds and i think it's more
likely that he blunders than but i don't know
about that b5 now he cannot extricate his knight
at all he has no ideas here but if he e3 if king
e3 there's b4 so he has like one so that is a as
a vicious trick before you could even ignore
okay wait but this is spiraling out of control
i almost feel like rotates g6 or f5 first and
just pushing these pawns is good at f5 and you
could even sack something and get these pawns
rolling like f5 gf ef king has to go to b7 right
you need one more move about rook a6 this is bad
here it comes rook takes b8 there was interesting
but instead he just pushes the pawns straight
through a g6 here just that easy just pushing
baby push him baby but it's not gonna be that
easy as it seems maybe you need the king's support
right because g7 rook takes f7 this is not
over oh it's so close rookie eight have rook f8
i'm just trying to be a clown but he was rookie
eight nine g7 oh knight check doesn't do anything
seven uh but this is oh g7 rook have seven he
had some forks uh he's gonna move but it's over
yeah he was indefensible and heartbreaking lost
seen there for a moment robert that wesley had
let this out of control but no resources coming
everywhere in a huge win extending the lead to
three points now let's bring the analysis board
up quickly just to show everybody how wesley not
just escaped but even thrived after blundering
a piece right incredible and we'll just go back
to that moment real quick here he thought that he
had pressure there were some tactics queen f7 says
well down goes your bishop but look what he did he
gives him a piece for just one pawn understanding
that black cannot fully develop because the knight
is pinned and so as we got forward here you were
right down here rook a6 rook b6 go after the
b2 pawn and try to make a draw but he went
for the win he was all in at this point even if
objectively the computer likes black's position
now the pawns were taught to defend yeah that was
that so let's go back to the live board as wesley
showed his might in that game he is up
eight to five plus three for wesley so far
in the three plus one smarter chess looking
well for lack of a better term quite smart
with the predictions and wesley once again
probably in a position that he's happy about
because i see these pieces all in line in the
center of the board and there's not even a threat
right now for white this bishop is not actually
under attack right and smart chest certainly
looking smarter than some commentator who shall
remain unnamed who may or may not have predicted
well something going in dude his favor but yeah
this position he's got that blockade going look
at those light squares on the queen side the
c4 square b3 square duda has control of the
center as you indicated but even c6 would
blunt the bishop on g2 so all of white's
alleged strengths are are sort of dulled here
and and i think blacks again got the initiative
reeling here is duda and wesley so
confident you could just sense it
complete control over the light squares
blacks uh pieces queen and bishop lined
up these pawns for white on dark squares what me
what happens if all your problems are dark squares
the light squares are your opponents for the
taking so quincy two he's claiming and done let
me know what you think about this that the three
pawns and the c through e files everyone's just
two pawns dne file so an extra central pawn
for white is that enough do you look at this
position and say oh i like white's center or do
you see the flow of black's pieces is overwhelming
yeah so that's a that's a good way to look at
the position now i would say this uh in the
context of a blitz game white's got in a certain
sense and i know this sounds crazy but he's got
the more stable position what does that mean if
black messes up he goes after a pawn thing spiral
out of control white's center could really make
its presence felt from an objective standpoint
i absolutely think black is better look at the
and wesley is doing a great job he didn't take
on a4 there allowing bishop b4 he's going to put
a knight on c4 he's going to establish a blockade
i think the window of opportunity for duda is
shutting closed very very quickly maybe bishop b4
try to get some a5 stuff in uh so there's stuff to
worry about for wesley he's got to be careful but
objectively i think he's significantly better here
and one big thing is that black can actually play
e4 file by f5 and close down the g2 bishop which
is trying to make its presence felt at some point
and we're talking about the queen side
light squares under black's control that
remains an issue and if you play e4 for white
challenging the bishop you're undermining in
a sense your own pawn structure in the center
the pawns are not protected by pawns anymore
they have to be protected by pieces and that could
be a problem exactly and now due to wow one minute
again it's you know i sound like a broken record
but it's a huge narrative of the match uh at
least here wow knight b3 i was going to say
the time situation look again the confidence
intermediate move attacking the rook does do
to have to play rook a2 can he sack no he does
now mate wesley maybe we'll take back on e5 or
maybe even not maybe he's looking for something
better exploiting that discovery on the rook i'd
be careful about that though but then i thought
about that but now cd i feel like white really
stabilizes in the center i'm not sure about that
i agree with you actually and look
at the extra material for black
you get a rook for just a knight in the pawn but
look how many pawns are in the center here and
you can't get e4 you would love to play e4 and
d5 now really continue pushing those pawns can't
get away with it there's nothing protecting the
e4 square definitely still better for black and
now what wesley can do is take on f3 and take
on e5 exposing the attack on the bishop on f3
and white center collapses i had a moment of doubt
there but i don't know what i was doing doubting
wesley who was don't doubt your spectacular
chess you should be confident i'm confident
in you you should also be confident thank you this
means a lot to me and c5 might make me confident
in wesley's position bishop c6 for perhaps
just to perhaps attack europe but even there
i think we might see that what's that guess of the
guess the move context again i think we might uh
contest we might have to participate in that
reference honestly i i've been looking to
see the people who have been leading indian
lad grand master nice narayan has been doing
very well in it dragon b70 as always and vavr
kirk these are like the three people that are
always at the top of guess what and here's d5 but
now that's c4 but i'm looking at this diagonal
and you're looking at that diode i am looking
at that diagonal you're also looking at the file
i'm looking at the f file and queen f3
can happen on the file so so based on
what we just said we just call it a draw you're
looking at one diagonal i'm looking at another
the other and the diagonals cancel each other
out yeah exactly five okay he did not like the
presence of that bishop on c6 that's a pretty
blessed decision though i like it though because
black has this past pawn that's much clearer
white's f2 pawn is that really a pass pawn
or is it a target oh that's only like
that because it might lead to a draw
i did ask for a draw so uh okay bishop d4 middle i
think it's a drop you're just trying to trade and
you you do have this past pawn but it's not going
anywhere it's what you're claiming at least in
queen c7 potentially just tying yourself to the a5
pawn white's got to be careful i agree but still
check and back okay and back so they're just
going to repeat can he brings rook to c8
you can sure try i feel like the thing is done
if we trade queens right black will be slightly
better in those end games yeah definitely
with a past spawn like this so no duda
he has to go for the attack on black's king as
weird as that sounds rookie one i would go for the
back ranker and after h6 maybe try to orchestrate
some h4h5 that's probably too slow okay going for
the activity now queen d1 and c3 robert oh wait
a minute he's gonna play rook c4 and queen c6 so
you're just going to gang up on the pawn uh anyway
or queen d1 just rookie one but no oh trying to go
for an attack be careful or maybe that looks f4 oh
but now we're back to d8 as possible and rook d2
oh this is spiraling out of control three seconds
that's why he he's not doing well in the club
yeah okay i mean c2 rook c4 no he's covering on
queen f1 here comes the king hunt queen f1 forces
the king out and where does it go so he goes he's
going by g2 and he has c2 under control so queen
f1 king h4 i guess and g5 that's just risky yeah
there must be some eight there but wesley also not
a lot of time g5 i think okay but g5 you could
lose that game king like you absolutely could
but i think you have to do it that's the only
check four seconds for wesley he's gotta move
all right kg4 right quinn h3 oh let's make sure
queen at five queen five oh oh he does this king
f7 he's gonna run but there's oh it takes what
com to do that which there has to be a mate quick
discovery nobody stops him where does the king
go what is wesley he's six seven king h73 queens
wow what an ending fireworks i don't think
that was that easy after queen d316 team d7
no that was i mean he's the second time we've
seen that incredible comeback and he loses on time
just when it seems he's completed it that was an
insane king march right his king went from g1 into
where to end that one e6 right wesley shaking has
said it i can't believe i let that king out but
he'll take it and that time management is paying
off in a big way you know it's done we've made
many sports references thus far and you take a
time out to gather yourself in chess when you time
out you just lose the game so unfortunately
for jkd here he has not found his footing
in this time but he is down four points right now
and we know how talented it uh don yeah you too
you also are very bullet but duda is in
the one plus one he beat fabiano eight
to one in that time control that's ridiculous but
something about wesley so there's something about
him that just is kind of due to his kryptonite
no he's just he's just good and he keeps the
pressure going and by the way this d5 move that
is a trap actually wait where was i falling into
again sorry no you're good there's if uh e4 ideas
is down his point but wesley got up from his chair
and i'm hoping he's bringing this cat that's
what i'm looking for i haven't seen wesley's cat
actually wow i i do like that chair though i think
we should analyze that that's a pretty good idea
so yeah duda is just he's reeling and as you said
wesley is playing all of the games at once the
time game and the chess game and he's not taking
his foot off the gas pedal it's not that wesley
doesn't make mistakes he does but when he makes
them he doesn't make them in pairs he recovers
he keeps the pressure going and it is
producing some excellent chess here
and once again duda is down quite a lot of time
here and you said you've walked in this e4 yep so
you have three pawns for the piece yeah but it's
not enough i think the end game end game is good
for white uh and i'm pretty sure well wesley's
thinking about taking the knight on c3 i don't
necessarily think he has to i mean he can take
the queen and just drop his rook back and it's
hard for black to coordinate his pieces uh and
he might end up losing one or two of his pawns
yeah i mean this bishop on g2 sort of catalan
style bishop always strong diagonal and you
will have control over the light squares but it
is three pawns dania says you have a difficult
time defending i i totally buy that but i don't
have experience in these lines i'm just counting
the material looking at the position white
is better how much is the essential question
yeah uh not winning for sure uh but duda's got
to be very precise i think queen takes queen
would at least take the heat off of the b-pawn
give black a tempo which he uses to bring his rook
into the game well he says no no no you're
going to defend that pawn and the move b6
it creates a structural weakness that leaves the
c6 knight undefended might not seem important but
guess what that catalan bishop your reference
that could make its presence felt as well
and the problem for black is when you have extra
pollens you want to start mobilizing those pawns
but white is the one actually attacking the a7
pawn if the a7 pawn moves to a5 then b6 is weak
now knight somehow you know i wouldn't think
this would be an essential pawn but this a pawn
having the ability to play a3 at some point to
make sure the knight doesn't get into b4 is really
important because otherwise black could play a5 in
knight before himself right that's a great point
every little detail is significant wesley
creating a g5 square for his knight with a move h4
very classy due to trying to cover up all of the
bases here but you can see he's hanging on by a
thread that knight from g5 can come to e4 and then
the b6 spawn is overloaded he can take on c5 this
is exactly what i sort of thought might happen
you know with with black's pawns he's got a lot
of them but it's so hard to sustain them robert
this is looking very bad you're totally right
94 takes c5 a nice threat of course you'd like
to take this bishop as well so what if i put my
bishop on d4 i know i don't want to give up my
opposite color bishop the dark soul bishop with
control of the whole diagonal but if you take
me and i can take with the c pawn don't i get
a pass pawn to work with as well that's a that's
a great call i think bishop d4 has to be played
you know whatever the objective evaluation and
he's got to play it very fast again he's down a
minute he's trying to put his bishop on e7 but
i don't know that's also interesting i liked
your idea though active yeah this is a bit more
passive you can't play f5 later right with an
e4 to kick it and he goes for this
so he doesn't want to trade pieces
and maybe that's a reasonable choice wesley dania
look at the clock wesley well ahead on time here
it's the story of in many ways it's one of them
not to take away from his uh superb play but
it just adds to his mastery that this management
of time it's so not too fast and not too slow it's
just perfect he always leaves himself enough
time to think through the critical moments
knight to c3 what is his idea how does he break
down black's defenses he doesn't have forever
due to deploying his pieces very nicely yeah and
how do you get this a7 pawn again well you don't
just black is tied down this rook on d7 would love
to start moving in to d2 for example but you drop
the a7 pawn once a7 falls down goes b6 so black
tied down here white sort of tied down as well
who is going to get the upper hand well rook
d1 is possible he can swap a pair of brooks
the question is is that a good thing they're
delaying wesley delaying on that for now
duda can just buy it his time but even that's
not easy to do does he have a king g8 or
something it's not easy to make a single move how
about f5 just say the heck with it i'm getting
active i like it he's 20 so you're just gonna move
you can't think you gotta make a decision come on
young kristoff not that we're rooting for either
player but it just feels like this is a trend
that we need him to fix for his own sake exactly
knight to c4 he's trying to dislodge the knight
from a5 he's using the opportunity black has
left the defile he has a moment in five seconds
robert they're just impossible to play in this
position okay he's attacking this this rook is
trying to come down d2 okay works not getting to
d2 knight c5 is possible but then rook d2 but look
he's giving up his bishop i think the bishop on d4
earlier would have been a better placement for it
but he's been playing fine it just now you can't
take it if you want but i don't think that wesley
does because the knight covers d2 as well it's
only a matter of time no pun intended is horrible
wait wasn't it is that a repetition
i feel like they had this before
we mentioned knight takes c5 he didn't play
it and okay bishop attacking this knight back
one second oh we barely got to move off okay but
nigel i mean wesley has so many ideas here look
at him just tightening the screws in one point
three seconds what do you mean he's gonna flag
it's sad to see because he's actually defending
really well robert he's actually not letting
wesley make that much progress and duda just
puts his hand out shakes his head and it's like
what hey i mean you have one second for
many moves throughout this match you're
going to be losing on time unfortunately
well something that's in i noticed and
not to be the monday morning you know armchair
general here they both of these players had
put me to shame in the opening but i feel like
wesley is just better prepared it seems like in
a lot of games there's a position in the opening
where duda takes 45 50 seconds in the five minute
portion that's kind of washed away by the time the
three-minute portion that's what sets things off
that's just one thing no you i mean you're right
you also get in some sort of comfort zone in five
minutes you start playing eight games of five
minute i can spend a minute on move 12 if i
wanted five minute because i still have three
and a half minutes after that a time has been
used but when you're playing three minutes
you spend all the time now you're down to
55 seconds to your opponent's two minutes
and you just don't have time to calculate
when the action heats up right exactly and
here we see again move 11 duda taking his
time wesley over two minutes 50. and again it's
the same this is what i'm saying there's that
moment in the opening he takes a long time he's
out of theory it seems wesley's still in prep
and wesley has also been doing a good job of
looking at the match timer so he's trying to
probably strategize around that as i don't even
know how big of an underdog wesley will be in the
bullet but i would definitely not say a five-game
underdog and that's what his lead is right now
but he has been keeping an eye on the
match clock and he has experience to know
if this position say looks level do i just make
a quick draw so i get another game in or you know
the position is slightly better for me let me just
play it out i don't mind getting into the bullet
as long as i can maintain my lead so that's what
you have to keep in mind as we get ready for the
final segment of this match indeed and look at the
time but in terms of the bullet if we look at the
ratings well yes dude us 32 30. wesley at these
are crazy 3004 but that doesn't again that just
doesn't tell the whole story i don't think wesley
plays that much bullet uh on chess.com and oneplus
one we've talked about it many times we'll discuss
it again uh before the bullet segment uh but that
changes the dynamic of you know of the games of
the match because it really adds that element
of thoughtfulness and takes away some of the crazy
time scrambles but here duda he's almost below a
minute that's a crazy time disparity he's down a
pawn i don't know he might be worse here as well
that's clock situation i was doing knight to b5
he is going after the a7 pawn knight c7 traps the
rook or doesn't wait there's rook c8 pinning the
knight so there are some ideas of course in the
position he has the bishop pair but daniel feels
like he's playing this out of more desperation
than actual strength yup and knight c7 rook
c8 such a tricky wesley always finding the
opportunity to pose problems to his opponent
force him into a decision black is better
i don't think white white is enough for the
pawn robert i it's just looking bad again
wow just not even easy to attack there's no
bishop h3 to go after e6 that makes sense
but when i see a move g3 done i immediately think
95 and knight into these weak squares he plays g4
and uh now he can absolutely take the bishop
fix the pawn on the dark square due to trying to
deploy his pieces actually h5 is interesting
he defends the night with that f6 instead
so confident so fast and and so strong all
around amazing play here and dude i'm not
able to stem the bleeding black's pieces
perfectly defended white's pieces look good
they're not accomplishing much and as you said h5
to defend this knight on g4 even if it gives you
a second set of double isolated pawns you open the
h file you're trading pieces you're in good shape
you are and 20 seconds now judah's just he's he's
just not yeah he's shaking his head he can't can't
find the zen uh it seems like each each position
is just not in his style and wesley's able to
channel these positions into his territory of
preparation and this is yeah this is looking very
bad again i i wonder what's going on with duda
though because there have been moments throughout
like right now his vision is particularly bad
but he's spending a lot of time he's gotta move
it doesn't feel entirely necessary so i just don't
think he he has the confidence that he had to
start out the match he was up two games early on
really yeah he was let's not forget that's how he
started he started with a bang and he was playing
amazing and then just something gradually happened
over the course of the five minute portion
which continued in the three minute portion
that's right and i'm glad to see so many people
here we have over 16 000 people on twitch right
now always good to have such an audience and
yes i am keeping my right eye on the chat and my
left eye on the game so traitor pieces so an extra
pawn still for wesley eight seconds left for young
christoph do you trade rooks and get into a minor
peace end game where you have a knight which means
you can go from color complex the color complex
and the bishop can't no he goes straight forward
we're going to keep the rocks robots you know
you're going to keep the rooks in here try to
throw your crucible knight d5 now he's got black
tied down white side down rock five is coming
oh and so methodical right that's the word that
comes to mind thorough methodical doesn't rush
activates all the pieces and uh just
torture here for yon i feel for him
i feel for man it's just hard to
make moves at this point it is
and at the very least wesley with five minutes
left this will not be the last game uh this will
be the penultimate game and does duda have chance
to hold he really cannot afford to lose this game
three seconds if if he had a little bit more
time i would have said yes the knights jumping
around hither in 95 knight f3 d3 there's so
many squares to account for uh doesn't matter
who it is it's almost impossible not to blunder
eventually yeah heather and dither will make
do the shiver i guess that was pretty
good i was like trying to you know i
was uh trying to come up with something there
i was wondering where you were going with that
well i was yeah i was gonna whatever we'll talk
about that later too yeah exactly seems like we
have some stuff to discuss okay so wesley oh king
e5 just total domination rook c1 rookie one mates
and i'm just shaking in my head g5 is just nope
not a single move just taking the air out of him
one more time wasn't rook c1 rookie
one made well rook c1 bishop takes c4
and then the pawn end game was winning
for black which is the original idea
let's show you played we'll
bring up the analysis board
yeah so rook c1 bishop takes e4 king e4 rook takes
d3 so you sacrifice a bishop for pawn to win the
knight but after rook c2 dania and i were thinking
this is just winning because if you're active king
and you can just go start taking pawns yep
or e5 anything wins there wesley uh singing
is he pulling a parham or well
what's probably on pulling a wesley
pulling a wesley means playing exceptional chess
and having a very lovely cat who joins you for
interviews and what else being super humble how
long i'm just throwing out all the things about
no he's awesome wesley is he's a class act and
he is he lets his moves do the talking and that
is the hallmark of a true professional and uh
that's exactly what wesley is he's he's been
amazing for a long time and he's putting that on
full display here not to take anything away from
jkd he's still very young he's so accomplished
and he's trying his best here we feel for him
we don't root for anybody uh but this is just
an amazing display by wesley and for duda he
is down six points and he played a line here in
this kind of bononi structure and his pawns on
g5 he's the pawn d6 that will you'd be tended
to not ideal he's tilting donya i i feel pretty
strongly that he's just yes yes angry at five
square and benoni there's certain openings that
they're not bad but you just don't really play
them unless you're kind of like alright whatever
not that he has a terrible position here
but definitely not what he was looking for
well he wanted to play f5 and swing that rook over
you're not getting an f5 when all of these pieces
are stopping that pawn from pushing right this
isn't good man this is not good it's a sibolita's
balloon to six again duda as we've referenced
the crushed fabi with a seven point margin in
the bullet so we won't rule anything out but he
needs this break robert he needs it really badly
i'm just trying to figure out what he can
do in this game and he's about even on the
clock so that's the good news for him but
the problem is he is struggling in both
areas of the board right center is closed so
the both arrows means the king side you have
to keep an eye on the g5 pawn the f5 square the
queen side the a6 pawn will need some tending too
the b6 square could be loose after a knight c4 uh
for not bishops or knight c4 you could also get a
b4 type of push in that's thematic and white's
king is going to be safe no matter what and you
can also castle you could keep your king in
the center with kiwi too you're spoiled for
choice i was just thinking about what wesley's
singing it sounds like an opera of some sort i
feel like wes leslie's opera kind of guy you know
it sounds wait you can hear him no it just looks
just the sort of expressiveness and i don't
know the motions it doesn't seem like a eminem
it seems more like i don't know giuseppe verdi
or something we'll have to ask him later whoa
what oh you see wesley just like i thought he
was looking wait well he seems that way but he
has an amazing position and he's upset but yeah i
saw that shake of the head maybe he's saying the
wrong lyrics let's say his position looks good
so i don't know what he'd be upset about here
maybe a song came on that he didn't like well
well well said daniel that was funny he fell into
a mondegreen that's a word i learned recently why
is he so why are you shaking his head and you with
your fancy vocabulary no it's i i was i didn't
know this right but that's what it means it means
a lyric that is commonly mis mis-uh cited right
like in a song you think it says one thing and
really it says another thing how would you
just uh you know teach people maneuvering
i don't know are we supposed to be commentating
any something else i mean why did they hire me
i thought i could just discuss this look
at the c file queen to c7 is coming in
yeah this doesn't look very good no i i'm actually
appreciative that you taught me that word i
now will undoubtedly use it incorrectly and i i
do enjoy miriam webster you know so my boy miriam
yeah you know what else is my boy the c file
and this is this is very very ugly this
position is a just a catastrophe for duda
yes this doesn't look uh so nice d6 is a weak f5
still problem the c file under white's control
wesley singing having a better time it looks
like now sax the exchange but queen d6 even
mcqueen d7 and he's just mowing vacuuming
up the pawns and blacks knights stumbling
against each other and the rook on c1 is not
doing anything it's a very nice idea by the
way sacking the exchange here i like it a
lot and king issue perfectly safe the king
on h8 may find itself in harm's way in the
near future but for now it's just all wesley
i'm out of words i'm out of words yeah i mean
this again uh to reiterate we you know we we
want to see great chess we love both of
these guys i can be painful to watch uh
this sort of thing happen but at the same time we
have to give tremendous credit to wesley he's been
he's been amazing uh for lack of a better word
takes g7 so measured so methodical and universal
and here he trades off as two pieces for the
rook he's a past d-pawn for good measure and
it's not actually that easy at least right now
to see how the game concludes but it's clear
that white it will conclude yes it certainly
will conclude there's no choice in that matter
but my point is that sometimes we think oh to
my piece against a rook obviously that's winning
and you start looking wait if i get a king f6
a knight f7 is it that bad yes yeah that's a
great question the minor pieces can have a very
hard time supervising a past pawn all the way to
promotion particularly as you said in the presence
of a rook which is why wesley's sort of trying to
stabilize consolidate maybe get the knight from e3
to d5 and c7 yep yes and he gets that one that's
a better pass spawn because it's protected
by the other one now knight back to c5 and
yeah judah's done a fantastic job here
resisting bishop d3 though tying the
knight down to the pawn looks like wesley's
going to grind him down one way or another
indeed and what wesley wants is bringing this
other knight into the game and he plays wait 964
oh that was a chance now knight c3 yeah that
this looks better than the next either still
my digital still okay blind spot for both
players yeah bishop 84 by the way that might
be a nice little win oh you i'm not gonna
finish my thought but you ugh i know that's
that's the perfect descriptive still bishop
a4 i like bishop how about 96 king h4g3
put a piece in a4 there it is there we go rook
c3 though oh no no g i thought g3 checked but the
king has h3 square well young christophedo will be
thrilled to be done with the three minute portion
um i am probably looking about as red as duda
feels but dania what a performance by wesley so
absolute domination every game every position
preparation middle games tactics positional
chess technique worst positions he pulled it off
this way and that way and the other way and on
top of that amazing time management just a tour
de force but we still have 30 minutes of below we
know what dude is capable of robert so i hope
nobody's going anywhere because there's still
some intrigue left let's see if there's gas
left in the tank for jfk james jfk oh my god
wow that was a yeah okay so for duda he did beat
five minute car one eight to one in bullet this is
a seven point lead for wesley so on
this wild note we are gonna send it
send us the break but we will have more of the
prom smackdown no between gotham chess and the one
and only you live hammer if you're a subscriber
please enjoy that otherwise enjoy the ads
okay my entire one minute
strategy is going into an end game
and i i just know that in an end game i'm gonna
win okay yeah i feel like strat though i feel
like this is well this is like going up against
khabib it's like you know what's gonna happen
there's nothing that you can do about it
i i'm i'm familiar with that reference
uh hammer what can we talk about
tell me what the reference is like sports i i
like sports yeah i like soccer the best sport
in all of the world aren't you norwegian aren't
you like not supposed to call it soccer uh i lived
in the us as a kid so i i got into bad habits
wow never recovered from saying soccer that's
that's pretty uh uh okay where'd you live
in the us berkeley california i feel like
this is way too polite for the smackdown i know
you know it's just i feel like i feel like you
need like a degree of comfort to engage in like
vicious smack talk and i just feel like we've met
like a few times you know i i can't really sit
here and be like yeah no that's my superpower
i'm just too nice people don't you know they
they are they're afraid to help me um not too
happy about losing all my pieces but what yeah
now i have to like buckle down here and try to
actually focus and not have
you flag me which is or or that
so this is my strategy the end game always
works okay yeah it was a blunder by me but
it works out kinda
wow no way you just did that i i dirty dirty man
oh i'm actually losing on time
no way you did that as well that was
an accident that that was unintentional
okay no more mr nice guy for me i grew up in uh
i guess i grew up in new york city if
you want to keep talking about childhood
okay this looks this this looks pretty decent
for me from the opening yeah no i mean the
entire opening is just horrible it's horrible
for black but somehow now you close down the h
file and i'm just better you think you're better
here yeah of course i am good control everywhere
i feel like i'm i feel like i'm creating a little
bit of uh how is their meta the thing is when
you play an opening as bad as this when you're
equal you pretty much feel like you're better
that's the advantage i see that's fair see
i i never make it to that phase of the game
generally when i'm playing so aren't you just
aren't you just like actually just worse now
we're we're discussing some serious
like meta strats here but uh
it's bullet it's bullet it's bullet
oh that that that is good that is
good that's nice and positional there's my style
um
so
well look what we have here donya the cat's meow
it's made its appearance finally this stream
wouldn't be complete without it this commentary
wouldn't be without that adorable image and uh wow
you know you don't sound like a cat person based
on how you're reacting i am no i love cats what
are you talking about i love dogs and i love cats
it really sounds like you're a cat hater based
on how you're talking right now what's up i'm
going to tell wesley i'm going to let him
know almost going to agree with commentating
in the next time but you just forfeited that
opportunity the cat i mean the cat is live
this is live footage of wesley oh adorable
oh bring the cat back yeah where's he going
okay well now we're gonna be back to the chest
wesley so has a seven game lead and as you can see
on screen look at the avatar next to wesley so's
name right down over here that is that's a cat
wow now i understand i actually i didn't know
you had a cat before today's match i'll be honest
well now you know and the cat makes a very
frequent appearance on wesley so's um matches
right yeah definitely are you trying to rub
in the fact that i didn't know you had a cat
not really but so you are a cat person no i
mean i i like cats and i like dogs like i'm
not one of those people who runs away when
i visit someone and they have a cat or a dog
gotcha like i wouldn't necessarily
spend an hour petting them but
you know i'm somewhere in the middle don't
worry a cat will not let you spend an hour
it's okay much less than a minute
that's that's what i've heard
yeah i mean the thing is i never understood
what we can have this conversation later as
well people are like i'm a cat person or a dog
person you could be both it's not that hard
anyway chest chest chest look at jkd look at jkd
he's back in his chair i think the problem for
him right now besides the seven nothing deficit
so nothing seven game deficit that he's facing
he needs to start winning like he doesn't have a
choice to make a couple draws to get himself in
the you know heat of the moment ready for the next
game he needs to just go he needs to be out there
at sacrificing pieces playing very quickly donnie
can you do it can he win by seven against another
super grandmaster one game at a time it's a cliche
but he's got to win this first one 30 minutes
let's remind everybody there isn't an hour there's
30 minutes of bullet there is enough time to play
over seven games there's about eight nine games
uh somewhere in that neighborhood which leaves
his margin for error practically zero robert
and he yeah he needs to win game after gaming to
forget about the lead and say okay i need to win
this game wins this game i need to win the next
one put everything behind him it seems he's done
that let's see how he fares yeah he's going for
it that's the way that's the way to do it now
wesley of course is not just going to let him
checkmate him that easily he did take though
and he opens up the uh the g file careful knight
f check right that's very important because you
would like to take and then take and then open the
whole board up but there's knight f three check
at the end of things when this knight gets here
right again he wants to get knight take d5 maybe
you have six to cover the bishop blunt the no whoa
that is bold okay that looks strange to me rook
takes e7 and knight f6 is a threat with those
kind of ideas nice wesley trying to create that
tension along the sea i don't think that helps
though if he takes because bishop e5 is still a
threat you lose your queen but then you take on
g7 you make oh nice in the windmill wesley
is not happy now he's got a small you know
he's he he's up seven points so he can okay
rookie seven rookie seven all right guys sorry
i missed it beautiful night of six i was calling
for it earlier you you did you saw it immediately
f4 though still winning yeah this is still looking
great for dude that was awesome this should be
five now bish should be five rook d7 oh insermento
not so flow fish should be six and knight takes e4
three pieces for a queen oh bishop f8 first even
yes that's nice so now two minor pieces and a rook
for a queen you know robert from my experience
in bullets specifically this can seem winning
it's very hard to play against the queen mark my
words it's very hard to play against the queen
where do you want me to mark them let me know
i want i have an idea of where i want to play i
have several thoughts about it i have a pen so
i'll mark them i have a pencil wait why is our
king on d2 so the rook was sacked for the bishop
the king is out in the open plenty of checks
yeah you're right though wesley's got good chances
here no yeah this is and there's so many squares
to queen e2 is almost mate queen e2 queen f2 for
example and you start mopping up the pawns right
that's a lot of puns queen h2 i mean you can just
start vacuuming up turn the dyson on and just take
him but look at this bishop takes b6 and then
white has a pass pawn right yeah well i don't
know who's pushing robert i think black is also
pushing they both are the bishop on f3 multitasker
stop being with a8 there's knight c6 ideas right
to stop that bishop from uh queen g keeping the
a square under control so maybe queen g two to
stop of that but then the h bond is progressed
bishop c5 is similar b6 b7 he's just going to push
the pawn slowly yeah the gates have opened e4 he's
got to try but i don't think that works but this
was close i mean i'm telling this took a lot
of time off of the match clock but he can afford
that as long as he carries this home was his game
but i think white's going to win yeah queen
d2 now king is safe lacking is safe for now
but not for very much longer now sacrifice
some of your extra material trade-off pieces
and five queen g2 nice queen g7 bleeding the
clock which is fine 27 made pre-move pre-move it
and he's going to flag him that is a win for jkd
and he did miss that tactic earlier and of course
his bullet chest things are going to be missed but
he put together a complete game and that's what he
needs he started off on a good note dania can he
get two three wins in a row now this game this is
the crucial game six has a different ring to it
than five wesley is so solid with white even in
bullet we have a slav slob is a good opening that
you b5 they're sort of a [ __ ] structure this is
a very combative line wesley is well prepared
here this is super theoretical he's got to not
get caught up in preparation it's weird to talk
about prep and bullet but the stakes are high they
certainly are and i agree with you duda should
not be venturing into theoretical waters and he
needs to make wesley think and then out play him
but it's very difficult to do outplaying wesley
freaking so but it's possible and he just should
not be going into theoretical territory where
wesley has seemed better prepared in this match
yep and he is again again we see and obviously
dude i'm not thinking for as long as he did in
the three-minute portion but i think he's in huge
trouble already look where is that night going
good night oh my lands and again and again he's
just getting in trouble in the opening wesley's so
well prepared he's dead i think lost for black oh
mm-hmm yeah maybe some chances but look at this
such a nice move it's like an intermessage that
isn't even necessarily urgent needed but he does
it and why are you not just taking on enough sick
h6 excuse me well he's thinking about f4 i think
he might be contemplating whether to play nope
just takes it and i like that okay judah manages
to more or less stabilize move the rook away
but um wesley can try to get his queen to g5
potentially cost him a pawn but the king on
h2 isn't the safest king in the world he gives
up the b-pawn he's going through it he's going
after e4 this is queen b6 threatens some kind of
night discovery oh nice knight g4 ideas yeah one
though he's trying to get knight g4 here as well
that's not gonna work knight e4 and bishop before
bishop g3 wesley brings his rook and he saw it a
queen h4 is definitely on the dock definitely oh
now you can't yes now some my discovery ideas but
i don't see anything specific i really want to put
that queen on h4 but he's refraining from doing so
well bishop takes g3 is a threat i would sack on h
i would just take on e4 twice give up that bishop
on h6 potentially no he keeps it bishop a6 though
okay so you can win in exchange for the queen 65
gets the queens off the queen he ordered the queen
what does he think he doesn't take him oh
he missed me oh my god my dude shakes his
head has wesley not seen it he didn't see it
wesley didn't react yeah no he didn't see it
oh my lance oh and it's this bishop on f3 you know
that could be a meeting net but it's still over
well it's honestly wasting more time unless he
did it on purpose that would be next level he
didn't take a freak no that goes against such base
instincts that i don't think even if he wanted to
do it that's like the well we'll pull up the uh
analysis board real quick just to show that one
more time because i was like am i missing a pin
here no no no you were totally right bishop e3
where the bishop was was here it moved back queen
h6 and the move bishop takes h6 was not played
what was the idea of queen hd can you like
let's forget about the what is he threatening
you're asking the wrong person
well unfortunately for jkd we get back to
the live board here he is now down seven
once more not too much time on the clock and for
wesley you're looking at this 22 minutes left
that means there's still time for jkd to
win every single game and tie the match
but the clock's ticking against you now right
well we've seen katie pull out some comebacks in
basketball will jkd pull out some comebacks and
chess i was i've been roasting that like pot of
bad coffee for the entire commentary yeah i'll
forgive you eventually but people are suggesting
hey maybe it was a mouse slip you want to go to g6
instead of h6 and maybe that potentially was the
case didn't look so good for black regardless at
that point but when wesley started to think i was
thinking is he going to miss it i thought maybe he
was just bleeding the clock before taking mcqueen
and it is possible that if that was a mouse
slip he was just being very kind saying oh
he slipped i don't want to take his queen here but
it wasn't kind in the end because he mopped up all
the pawns in one right and now not a position
conducive to too many winning attempts wesley
with the strong bishops and the open d-file
controlled by him yeah this just doesn't i mean
duda is is a fighter he's going to fight to the
last drop of blood but if wesley can get another
one here that makes it very very unlikely
rook d3 is possible as an intermediate move
that's very nice plant that rook on the
square you can also put the bishop back to
no longer back to b5 but let's say king e2 you
had bishop b5 check and here comes the rook yeah
b5 or bishop a3 i mean so many attempts f5 even
like f5 just go for the center mm-hmm king e2
probably necessarily then even e34 and his
rookie three check look at those bishops just
cooperating all of the p wesley always has such
well-coordinated pieces i know it's again it's
a trivial statement maybe but so healthy in his
pawn structure the way that he arranges his pieces
he's a little good at chest i don't
know if you know can you take that you
take enough three or sixty about that too
wait you think you might have been able to
huh taking on f3 seems nice i guess and
i'm just trying to sacrifice the pieces
but yeah look what he did he put his bishop
on d5 bishop one c5 rook on e3 the guy plays
perfect chess sometimes where all of his
pieces are optimally placed and his opponent
is just struggling to come up with ideas he sees
everything he's a machine as someone tends to say
yeah this is so the evo went down but it wasn't
because he won well he didn't make the most out
of this but now he's got the pass pawn and
again he's bleeding more clock so he doesn't
even really need to win i mean as long as
he even makes a draw yeah but due to very
nice defense here you sort of stabilize the
situation knight on e3 doesn't look so good no
and offering the exchange of bishops see that's
just it goes to show right down here that if you
trade dark square bishops you're not gonna make
progress because a light square bishop can't
attack dark squares and their inherent limitations
to the pieces this is just a nightmare not lost
now yeah i mean with two seconds on the clock
king's i mean wesley is so many it's bishop d4
stopping every threat if you notice it can be easy
to miss in the heat of the moment how he's just
strangling him i mean not a single idea he
allows and that playing style has is uh a rare
sight nowadays well not really but wesley
takes it to an absolutely different level
epic that's why he's so hard to beat because he
is an extremely precise player oh okay not quite
just quickly bringing up the analysis
board if white had one more move to take
on a fourth day draw because wrong color
corner with this bishop so you need those
to match and if you could take on e4 you just
sit your king back in the corner theoretical draw
knd5 says resign time sorry buddy that's that and
we have a new game we have wesley with an eight
point lead yep danya eighteen and a half minutes
left i don't think these will be the happiest 18
plus minutes of young christophed his life no
these yeah no definitely not and uh when it
rains it pours i think that under different
circumstances you know maybe he could have
pulled out a bullet come back we won't rule
anything out uh you know the intrigue is possible
until the last second and we remind people that a
big portion of the prizes are based on the actual
result so there's a lot on the line uh but
yeah it's just and and one can only feel the
pain these kinds of matches you have no recovery
time you talked about this before can't take a
breath and that's part of the fun but it's also
part of the pain when things don't go your way
absolutely and as you said the prize fund there's
three thousand dollars to the winner of these
quarterfinal matchups plus three thousand dollars
split by win percentage and right now wesley so
he's getting a heck of a lot of money yeah he
is that's what i'm noticing in the confidence
52 seconds he's every move is just increasing
and enriching the pressure it's incredible
he's trading off the queens if the knight goes
to b5 to avoid the queen shirt e6 comes and you
get pressure here rook f1 the brook has to
go to f8 and you take on a7 he's in flow and
you know that's a famous concept i think in
psychology coined by the most unpronounceable
psychologist of all time but we just feel
it you know he's in the zone one second per
move increasing the pressure and uh and here
comes the nigel short king walk yep exactly
so i'm looking for him looking
for this king to run out here
due to trying to hold things
together with his knight
okay if you could play knight
takes c5 that'd be a good move
right we talk about capturing our own that's
right knight d4 to c5 and here comes the king
yup king e4 k85 sure as the sun will rise
oh first he's got a setup so now that i
can't go back to e6 because of rook takes c6
it can't go to f5 to win h4 but i don't
think that wesley's so worried about that no
going after the pawn back to d7 and
finally dude all right all right okay
knight c5 is a threat so careful now
i've had enough that's what he said and
by the way wessey's rating 3026 in bullet that's
absolutely underrated yeah i think he might just
be a little bit better oh yeah i actually played
him quite i mean this he should be at least 3200
i mean it's weird to speak in those terms
all these ratings are astronomically high but
this guy is uh he's insane well here actually
duda with a massive defense it's a draw now oh
knight of an a4 no d check yes you both have the
same regulator maybe practically oh yeah knight
and look at wesley that's the first time i've seen
him be upset about his gameplay he was upset about
the music earlier right now he's like how did i
allow this fork and now i'm down two pawns yep
and now it's over how much time is that 15 minutes
for what will be seven games needed by jkd he's
gotta win he's gotta give some scholar mates i
think wesley's known to miss them once in a while
well maybe we'll see you know some sacrificial
play yeah we tend to see some fireworks toward
the end when and that's fun indeed and okay the
e5 pawn is just done working for check nice little
technique and there's nothing that white can do
here he's gonna go king h1 oh oh look wes he's
running out to laugh that's why his hand over his
face yeah it's always funny because you never see
gm's own super gms playing out until
checkmate right every second matters though
there we go do it a wins one seven to fourteen
is our score and duda the kind of face that
is like yeah this just ain't going my way and
he's trying to go into the king's gambit he's
had enough of all the talk about the queen's
gambit so here he's making bobby fischer proud
and as you see the odds to win the match obviously
wesley's dancing head at the beginning didn't look
very good because smarter chess thought that
duda would win the bullet portion but then
after wesley went on a tear when all those
three minute games of course he's on top
right and um well dude with the michaela moroney
not impressed face the universal symbol of like
meh but he's trying and i respect the grind
king's gambit now going back old school yes and
the queen's coming to h4 there's pawn on f7 the
pawn f4 is falling i kind of like this for white
i do and i think what i've learned is just don't
argue with smarter chess because smarter chess
is not smarter than chess but smarter than me
also i think it should be renamed smarter than me
i don't like the name that's bad for branding
but i see your point all right h6 played
bishop takes f4 kind of bishop e5 yeah but
uh okay but now f3 becomes possible trying
to shatter the defenses around white's king
potentially i'm into it knight g6 instead
very clinical again just keeping the f4 pawn
which is shutting down white's pieces from
playing to their full potential wait why don't you
take the bishop first so he could have taken the
queen of two and one right after
f4 instead he allows the bishop to
rewrite itself this is bad the problem sorry go
ahead no i didn't say anything uh no you just
made a very profound point i wanted to want
you to repeat bishop f4 queen g3 by the way
is an interesting tactic uh but i was going
to say like openings like the queen's camp
like the king's gambit are you know they're fun
but at a high level it's important to understand
they're just so well analyzed that it's just taken
some of the intrigue out of these openings some
people sometimes wonder why don't they play those
openings anymore it's not out of a fundamental
lack of respect for old school openings uh it's
not that the players don't want to have fun it's
just engines have you know they've made a dent in
some of these speculative lines they have indeed
and you know just not gonna work out for the most
part one thing that black would like here is a g7
to g5 to protect that pawn but you would have
to move the knight first oh that's it's so sad
as a chess player when you win material but you
actually lose material right back so right one
in exchange but the rook is hitting well bishop
look at dude that's the game here up in exchange
he bobbed a little bit do you see that yeah he's
vibing bishop c3 or just take on g4 either one
yeah but rook fe-8 some chances i would
try to grant him a background potential
g1 rook is trapped look at that and he sees
it and duda another win he's giving himself
a fighting chance 11 minutes
and it'll be a six point game
is there enough time for six games if he plays
very fast remember remember you just need to
be able to start the last game start the last
game basically it's doing five games right which
is still difficult considering 11 minutes
but okay but he needs to start pre-moving
everything you can't start thinking about how
to convert this you need to get down to business
yeah now i have mulan stuck in my
head so thank you for that let's
get down to business yeah let's not sing that
song in the middle of a chess broadcast but
it is stuck in my head um i didn't see
the new live-action blonde did you 1966
and that's me okay go home you're through and
uh dude is not through yet he's trying his best
yeah he's he's having a better time i
wonder if the stress is kind of off because
he knows that wesley is going to win this match
more or less so he's a little bit more relaxed
which allows him to play better bullet perhaps
but on the same uh token here wesley might be
too relaxed because he got to such a big score
so you never know how that's gonna play out
yeah you never do and uh now wesley with a
peaceful opening sort of stabilizing all he
really needs is a draw to stem the tide and here
we do see duda look at the time he's moving fast
he recognizes the urgency he hasn't lost hope
and i actually love that robert about these
matches and the fighting spirit displayed
by these players you never see them sort of
you know hanging just ah you know that's
that's it let's just uh screw around now
they're fighting to the last drop of blood the
problem is we have a very symmetrical end game
wesley with a very savvy strategy because
he doesn't lose these end games often
just typical wesley so just playing a nice
solid approach and i think black is better
you have both your rooks out your king is on f6 it
seems like you're a little bit ahead oh 94 isn't
that's a good call just to be cool stays with
the pawn just imagine if he if he pre-moved 94
exactly okay we'll actually take d1 and then
go rook d2 don't laugh robert do not laugh
ladies and gentlemen black is better
again black is much better winning a pawn
he needs to go very fast he needs
to win this within 30 seconds
no that's not happening wesley also
has 31 seconds remaining on his club
sometimes you make good points robert
i have to confess despite myself
yeah it's just you know there's a doctor
in spite of himself and there's a donya
in spite of himself here so i i didn't get
it to play don't worry about it so yeah so
it's upon before can you just capture it yeah
but this is not very winnable is it with the
spawn structure has fixed it dude has to try to
get his king over to d5 and c4 so push the pawn
to b3 get the king to c4 and win that the good
news is in this structure though danya is the g6
pawn isn't all that important because look at how
black's pawns remaining pawns they stop they stop
the play right so you have stolen a pawn but it's
like you're not even up a pawn on the king side
ladies gentlemen you took your seat
belts off thought we arrived at the
garage turned the car off let's put
those seat belts back on for a second
and who's gonna wrap up the engine is it gonna
be you i'm right yeah i always rub up the i'm
the kind of rev up the engine kind of person
you seem like it very high energy needing to
prove yourself and just show everybody that
you're in a in my cruising in my ferrari
yep yeah totally ferrari kind of guy hey you know
i i hope that wesley's listening the song fast car
by tracy chapman that'd be good for cars by
gary newman you've you're plenty of options here
and dude is completely winning he's got
to go over the speed limit here though
i was done with the car references for now wow
he's only gonna be down five but there will be
in rookies roommate pre-move it yep wesley
wesley doing by the way anybody who's saying
ah why is wesley this is completely within
the rules and he's doing the right thing
okay the time match clock is as legitimately a
part of the match as the position on the board
he's doing what he can yeah and i know that i saw
mention of pharaoh sayo's match against there is
a frugia what fedocide did almost cost him the
match so this is nothing new can you remind me
he made a draw in a position where he could have
just kept playing for a bunch of moves and still
made the draw against alerissa and then oh did
end up winning yup but it was a nail biter so
it's not against the rules it is actually not
unsportsmanlike it's perfectly reasonable thing
to do both players know the strategy both players
um have done been on both sides of wins and losses
in these matches so wesley is uh within his
rights and doing absolutely nothing wrong
side no exactly and he's also just a classy
person and then a true professional so he's
he has a reputation and then he yeah again well
within his rights and and here he's got a great
position something went terribly wrong dude
with another vienna king's gambit but this
one went terribly wrong he stacked upon but look
at wesley's pieces sandwiched there in the center
not enough compensation this not looking good oh
it is not and the knight can't be down you you
want to play g2 takes imaginary piece on f3 that's
the best move that's been the theme of the match
imagine if bonds could move diagonally one
square without capturing every now and then
levitating over to f3 i'm here for it wait
bishop g5 queen e5 that's a nice find by wesley
always these small tactics 94 yes sir
nope defend the pawn for just so surgical
this is not fun for this is no jkd
horrific position but he tries footy
county six to open up the bishop he needs
to catch maybe wesley on some pre-move
queen from my book queen d4 and hope that the
queen moves away from the g7 pawn that's your
only hope here well you know one of the dirtiest
tricks in the book he did it whoa it's exactly
c5 though shutting down all hopes and dreams
wait a minute no 92 well that is a gnat that
is just that is beyond nasty you can't even
stop it like rook through this queen one god
and it's over i was going to say one of the
dirtiest tricks in the book so when let's say
you play rook c8 and your opponent has a rook
on c1 right so white takes rook takes c8 and
he assumes that you're going to recapture the
rook on c8 so he pre-moves but instead you make
another move for example attacking the queen right
and so yeah i actually i think i call this the
ferrous trap or the one random trap i i'm gonna
hear for it i'm here for it it makes a lot of
sense if you your opponent anticipates um response
or recapture they pre-move something and so you
make a move like knight to b5 right you've got
to do it sparingly you got to do once in a while
otherwise your opponent catches on and it loses
its effectiveness agreed anyways i'm not sure why
if chess.com is paying me to talk about dirty
bullet tricks but wesley he doesn't need them
he has the skill and look at this blockade
on e4 he's going to put a bishop on e4
yeah then you move your king away and play f4 and
just open up this f file against chris exactly
this is a good illustration of well first an
attack but in general double pawns right people
are like oh well they can't protect each other
another thing is if you capture with a pawn in
an adjacent file you leave yourself with isolated
pawns so you can just threaten upon and then try
to open up the file and rooks don't do well behind
double pawns because you can defend the first one
but not the second one so it's just a nightmare
of a situation to have and that's why duda gave up
in exchange that's a great insight and um rook
h1 now wesley trying to prepare h5 although duda
can keep things shut uh with with the g5 and
he's trying to create chances himself queen f5
very resilient even until the very last second
of the match okay don't play f3 the queen comes
into e2 and even here look at that don't take on
e5 because f2 is hanging rook takes f4 threading
both rook h4 and rook f2 this looks like a
disaster yeah wow what a turnaround but wait
a second there's some beautiful lines here look up
for queen d8 king g7 h6 dg3 exposing the discovery
i know what you were trying to do but okay
i don't know what to do for black now 18
seconds he doesn't do either so what do you
do here because what did he do okay he took
he was afraid of that h6 move as he took no that's
not what you want nope but but still i mean okay
black is not winning
no but i should know but i mean okay
but maybe somehow i'm in rook g5 okay
the rooks are too good here
rook takes h5 yeah this is
maybe not winning but it's definitely good
for white e3 it's rock h7 now it looks winning
for sure
all right yeah this is winning oh for somebody e2
e2 severing the connection between the rooks and
wait a second why can't even deliver perpetual
robert rook g7 king f8 you can take and take it
off yeah wesley always has that trick in the
end or rook g7 and rook f7 oh that was also
an option here i don't know why i'm getting this
excited about this game but because you love end
games you love it i do a lot of end games i always
say i don't like them on my stream but at my heart
i i feel like end games are they're beautiful
look at the perpetual there's so much tactics
and so much under the surface of an end game that
looks completely innocuous and that's amazing
and what speaking of amazing this repetition
here yeah it is amazing it doesn't seem can
escape not every day yeah exactly and we enter
the final game of quite possibly the final game
of the match with a minute left on the clock
and a six point lead retained by wesley cell
wesley is a little bit good no i'm not doing
my wesley cell impression by the way everybody
but wesley he'll move on to face the winner
of hikaru nakamura versus vladimir putin sev
and hikaru of course is the favorite in
that matchup but i would not be counting
fedocide about out if i were all of you in the
audience here fed us a very strong player whom
hikaru respects a lot and said as much in the
post-match interview last time we saw him so
that match will determine who wesley faces
and if wassey does face hikaru nakamura we
saw hikar beat wesley in the championship last
year i don't know it's always difficult for
anyone to play hikaru but wesley has the style
that if he's in tip-top shape he really can
go head-to-head with the car maybe the bullet
is where hikaru has the biggest advantage but
yeah wesley will definitely make that a very
serious match and if wins of course try to say if
he has a chance against anybody including magnus
and carol yeah is a good friend of mine and i
you know i believe in him i think he's an
amazing player he's given a car trouble
but of course nakamura is unmatched across the
board really and uh we'll see i mean wesley will
have to really bank on the five and three minute
portions we see his prowess in the three-minute
portion particularly now in two matches uh
incredible yeah well and looks like we have some
and we have some westlake is like what yeah once
he's gone he's like come on this match is over i'm
getting my cat although if you think about it a
draw because some of the prize money is based on
win percentage draw helps at the very least helps
duda right so not that they're really counting
yeah bills maybe they'll just agree one in
the spirit of the gentleman that they are
i mean that's not the worst timing
for i've had some issues with uh
internet disconnections and timing
recently i think i know all about that but
yep well we know how the match has concluded
in wesley's show's favor we were just talking
about you know a potential matchup with a car
and nakamura we'll see if a car can get through
fedor save donya it was really impressive
by wesley though we really have to give him
credit because he was losing to start the match
he was down two games in the five minute portion
before winning the last couple to even that
up and then the three minute wesley soh is the
best player in the entire world in three plus
one time control you heard it i mean the speed
confidence the ability to recover from a loss
especially as you pointed out robert the first
two games judo went out of the gate so strong but
the and also the opening preparation legendary
let's not forget duda himself is an opening
juggernaut in so many games wesley displayed
incredibly deep preparation across the board
in many different openings both colors as well
as surgical filigree precision in converting
advantages in every time control he had the
whole package today this is a well deserved win
we feel for duda he tried his best he fought very
hard but today was not his day and congratulations
to wesley indeed we will have the players on for a
post-match interview but for now enjoy the finale
of the primetime smackdown between gotham chess
and hammer flagged when here i'm just getting
annihilated oh man and people will see this
i will be humiliated yeah it's a disaster
yeah it's it's really it's really not good
man it's gonna wait it comes down to okay oh yeah
you do this thing where you don't resign right no
i never resigned that yeah it's a decent strat
wow this is the it's a close it's close match
are you nervous shut up
yeah so here i didn't put my knight on h6 which i
should have now this becomes a bit uncomfortable
like this the other day on stream oh you played
against me on stream the other day yeah remember
toward the end you like challenged yeah it did
not go well how did that go do you remember what
i said right before sending you a challenge uh
love your stream a big fan from norway uh i don't
believe that is what i said okay what did you
say i believe i said something like play me nude
i don't really i don't have
recollection of that um but yeah i uh
i can definitely see you saying that what was
the score again it i just like we played a bit
you know yeah it was interesting it was it was
competitive yeah yeah i believe the score was
quite significant to my advantage i i don't
remember i'm sorry i i think it was 6-1
positions also resembled this one i should
say in in that match i'm liking my chances
yeah this is uh
oh you clutched it out you clutched it out
let's go let's go that's how you do it people
after an excellent quarterfinal matchup we
have both players in the call wesley and young
christoph thanks for joining us wesley have to
start with you congratulations on what was a very
impressive performance and i must ask you started
off down two points how did you write the footing
you know not only tie the score but then go
on to really have one of the most impressive
performance ever in the three minute time
control yeah thank you actually yeah i just uh
i started with half a point out of
three and uh i just took a deep breath
and tried to move on forget about the past and
focus on the current game that's you know with
blitz it happens also quickly and you have to
focus on one game at a time and and forget about
what happened in the past win or lose yeah how do
you keep that composure though because a lot of
people will go on tilt but it seemed like you
were still pretty calm throughout yeah i just
take a deep breath try to play solidly try
to play what you know the best uh try not
to blunder anything if you can make a couple of
draws usually the tilt will go away try to play
positions that you that you are comfortable in
and try to get opening positions where you're
happy and don't take unnecessary risks uh but
of course easier said than done and also the uh
if you're it depends also on your opponent yeah
well ian joseph uh sorry that the match should
not go your way but congrats on a very well played
match nonetheless uh from your perspective what do
you think contributed to the turn around after the
initial uh great start in the five minute portion
yeah i think that this neither game was russia
like um i think i would play him but somehow
like i couldn't have found a pincher and i
decided to go for his end game and it was very
like heartbreaking i lost this one versus two so
yeah after that i mean it started to go down here
this game at all so yeah yeah and since then
i started to definitely like i tried to forget
about it and to focus on childhood it wasn't yeah
i just couldn't do it and yeah he also played very
well like my special only three plus one section
i just couldn't like predict any of his moves so
yeah that makes a lot of sense and one question
for you wesleyan congrats again on an amazing
match uh do you sort of think through the strategy
before the match in terms of where you want to be
after each section where you consider yourself
a favorite or does that is that not part of your
preparation you just decide to play one game at a
time how to what extent do you think that through
yeah i mean it's very hard to predict
exactly what would happen before
but i think it's pretty obvious that jan kristoff
is a better bullet player than me based on ratings
so i kind of needed to be ahead by uh preferably
two points before the bullet so i was keeping
that in mind and uh also i don't really want to be
behind in the five minute portion either and uh so
uh yeah i just have to keep in mind that hopefully
i'll be up a game or two before the bullet
but and then because of my lead during the bullet
games i could kill time in in many of the games
and that worked well but definitely i'm sorry
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off how about ahead
yeah i was going to ask young kristoff you know
on your side of things when when it wasn't going
your way in the three minute did you have a
number in mind that you needed to be down by
this many points to have a chance in the bullet
yeah i actually lost control over the score so
you know i was quite surprised to see
that this you know 25 or so but yeah i'm
yeah okay i just yeah i was blundering vlogging
every game so it was once definitely like
you know how to keep the score and
yeah i mean yeah definitely i mean i
should have done something i mean but i don't
know what exactly so yeah yeah but i must say
also that it was i knew it was going to be a
very tough match because i played yankers off
two years ago but he's improved a lot as a player
he's become more stable his openings are better
and i knew he felt very comfortable
in unclear and complicated positions
so actually he was getting very
good position with this bishop g5
italian game so so i i had to avoid that oh cos
before the match i wasn't sure exactly if i'm
going to get good positions out the opening but i
was just trying to to get the feel of where i'll
get comfortable positions and of course what
happened the three-minute portion was totally
unexpected for everyone yeah and speaking of
getting comfortable it seems like your cat
is a very comfortable in your arms right
now wesley so we all love your cat and i
do have a question for you because were
you listening to music during the match
no i actually no i was thinking okay that's right
we thought you were singing but we weren't sure if
you also listen to music so you know what kind of
music do you listen to or were you singing to you
know help you out to the match oh yeah funny i
was listening to bg yesterday nice so the songs
yeah but but but it's fine because i was i knew
i was tilting in the very beginning of the match
so i just had to change the rhythm and i had
to change the setting right away so i figured
singing and talking to myself
with the microphone off
with microphone mute it won't hurt anybody and it
it worked it made me feel more comfortable then
just try to forget about the tilt yeah that makes
sense and young chris you weren't listening to
anything right you were just playing no music or
anything yeah trying trying to play good chances
yeah i don't know it's weird like some players
are very distracted by music well some players
like hiko i guess play better
with music or i'm like daniel
do you listen to music well sometimes but i
play worse but i still listen to it because i'm
too addicted to music i know i'll play badly
regardless well we're gonna let you two go but one
last question for you wesley uh you will face the
winner of hikaru and uh fedocev and you know we
know your history with hikaru including the final
of last year's speedchest championship but what
are you going to do to get ready for that match
up or are you going to wait to see who you play
uh yeah i have to wait to see who i play first
of all i think they play on december 3rd right
something like that i haven't checked the date
yeah yeah so first of all yeah we have the magnus
the first magnus chester this sunday so it's
going to be a longer time control and i'm going to
play in that tournament
that's gonna take quite a bit
and uh we'll see what happens hikaru
is clearly the favorite in that match
and uh in any match unless against magnus he's
the favorite so it's going to be uh tough uh
yeah i don't uh really want to think about
hickory yet but i'm going to have to play a
lot of bullet games and end it well that makes
sense and in the meantime again you know chris
i'm sorry the match shouldn't go your way but
we always love having you in the field you
made it through a tough invitational just to get
here so we're definitely proud of you many fans
out there who are supporting you and wesley to you
another great performance another excellent match
and please say hi to your cat for me uh you know
zanzibar cute the cat i love cats so uh we really
appreciate you joining us for the post office
interview all right thank you yeah great match
yeah there you heard it from the players it was
a tough match they really have great respect for
one another and we're starting to have great
respect for javakir 40 because no this isn't a
repeated graphic this feed a master wins the
75 dollar guess the move every single time
and dragon b70 looks like a throne you've been
kicked off it you're in second with 50 bucks
and indian lad and grand master 25 and congrats
again to lapree and ananth sc for gaining some
memberships to chess.com fantastic stuff good to
see people engaging uh with with the match and
speaking of matches we got so many more coming
up as we see these mouth-watering names wesley
uh of course advances but vladimir fetish have
any car nakamura that is a heavy hitter matchup
that we'll have on uh december the third i think
we said that's what wesley said so yeah that's
the word on the street but we got some guy whose
initials are mc that guy might have something to
say about the proceedings of the sec as well so
so much stuff coming up ahead certainly we have
our remaining quarterfinal matchups before we
get into semi's adventure the finals but donya
this was an excellent display of chess from wesley
so as he said himself when he got down two games
he was trying just to find his footing over the
board get positions that he felt comfortable in
and most importantly he did not want to freak
out and let the match get away from him he is
amazing right the way he played that match leaves
a lot to study honestly on just how he was able to
outplay such a strong player like young christoph
duda absolutely we talked about all of the amazing
skills that he displayed today including but not
limited to opening preparation time management
and just presence of mind lack of tilts he talked
about some of it in the post-game interview and
all of that came together in a nice
package a consummate professional
very classy person and a joy to watch not to take
anything away from jkd who put up a tremendous
fight but wesley the deserved winner today robert
i would agree with that and you know he plays so
well that i feel stumped and i'm always just
calling his chest amazing and it's like well
robert you're getting repetitive but that's the
type of performances that wesley so gives us
he moves on to the semifinals his record in the
speed chess championship is really something that
you just have to look at like that guy only gets
defeated by hikaru nakamura and if you look at his
match history magnus hikaru those are the people
who have taken them down so wesley he knows his
works cut out for him he calls a car the favorite
in any matchup he plays except if he plays magnus
carlsen he has more chests to be played in
longer time patrols and that adjustment can be
difficult too but dania enough about the players
i want to thank you for being my co-host today
i know we have our friendly ribbing but at the
end of the day i'm always so thrilled that you
join me for the commentary i have a great time
i also learned quite a bit from you so anyways
thanks for teaming up with me today i
wouldn't think of doing with anyone else
i always enjoy it robert you're awesome and
yeah ribbing aside i always have a great time
and you're a big part of the reason why and the
other big part of the reason why is of course the
thousands and thousands of you who were joining
joining us throughout this match a huge shout out
to everyone taking time out of their busy tuesdays
and watching this amazing match by tuesday by
tuesday you do mean thursday right thursday i
can't even say this probably i was thinking about
title tuesday and so it escaped my mind man but
who knows what day of the week it is anymore it's
times have changed haven't they i quite literally
just told you what day of the week it's thursday
i know it's thursday yeah no i disagree robin
it's tuesday it's actually it's my my rules it's
tuesday oh no no this is the t it's the same okay
anyways we'll leave that for the next match but
all jokes aside an amazing match and robert
thanks to you and thanks to everybody for
uh for watching yeah i definitely want to thank
all of our moderators our producers behind the
scenes making this such a seamless broadcast
you really make it our lives so much better
by chatting with us it just becomes much more
enjoyable so thank you once again for being a
part of the chess community and for uh being
a fan of chess.com and the events that they
uh put on for you so on that note enjoy the rest
of your thursday we will see you soon for more
chess action and more from the speeches
championship brought to you by chess.com
give up that bishop on h6 potentially no he
keeps it bishop a6 though okay so you can win
in exchange for the queen 65 gets the queens
off one blood on the queen you order the queen
what does he think he doesn't take him oh he
missed it he's saying oh my god that dude shakes
his head has wesley not seen it he didn't see
it was he didn't react yeah no he didn't see it
you